Bris Perrier, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Est-ce
que vous voulez bien vous présenter
succintement ?
Et ben donc je m'appelle Bris Perrier,
je suis journaliste indépendant.
[grognement]
Euh j'ai travaillé pour différents
magazines. J'avais commencé un peu dans
le documentaire
en gravitant pas mal entre Paris et la
Savoie parce que je suis originaire de
là-bas. J'avais monté aussi un journal
dans les années 2000 en Savoie et
j'écris aussi des livres tout seul ou
avec des autres personnes. Et là ben je
viens d'en faire un sur les origines du
Covid-19, du virus du Covid-19.
Donc, on a décidé de vous faire venir
parce que ce sujet-là nous intéresse. Et
ce sujet-l nous intéresse parce que
au départ de cette crise, en 2020, il
était très touchy d'aborder la question
sur les origines du virus et de poser
des questions sur d'où vient ce virus,
comment vous avez travaillé
sur cette enquête, sur ce virus, comment
vous avez fait pour collecter et
d'ailleurs pourquoi vous êtes intéressé
à ce à ce sujet là ? Les origines du
mal,
les origines du livre. Donc ben en fait
à l'automne dernier mois, moi je suivais
un peu de loin hein l'origine du virus
depuis le début, mais euh c'est vrai que
c'était pas un sujet qui était très euh
très poussé parce qu'on a tout de suite
euh mis en avant euh le pangolin, euh
l'origine naturelle et puis euh penser
autre chose. C'était bah c'était taxé de
complotiste he pour résumer la
situation.
Et puis à l'automne dernier, il y a un
directeur de recherche du CNRS s'appelle
Étienne Decroly qui a fait une interview
sur le site du TNRS
où ben où il disait que la question
devait être étudiée sérieusement,
c'est-à-dire sans sans évacuer aucune
hypothèse
et qui disait que l'hypothèse d'une
fuite de laboratoire accidentel était
pas du tout à comme complotiste parce
que c'était une éventualité
à regarder comme les autres en fait Et
euh
moi j'ai trouvé que ce qu'il disait ça
m'a intrigué, ça m'a interpellé. Euh
j'ai je l'ai contacté et j'ai j'ai
proposé des papiers, des interviews
autour de ce thème différents journaux
avec lequel je travaillais qui n'étaient
pas intéressé
et
du coup bah je j'étais aussi en contact
avec Olivia Rocassins qui est mon
éditrice pour d'autres projets et je lui
ai suggéré de faire un de proposer à
Étienne de Croly pourquoi pas de voir
avec puis c'était intéressant de faire
un bouquin quoi. [grognement] Et il
était bah il avait pas le temps en fait
de se consacrer à ça parce que quelqu'un
qui bose beaucoup
et et donc bah Olivia m'a dit "Ben
vas-y, fais-le toi." Et donc voilà bah
j'ai donc je suis parti à à
débroussailler le sujet. Et euh
Combien de temps ça a pris ?
Ah, ça a pris j'ai passé 3 4 mois à 100
% dessus quoi. Au début en
débroussaillant et on était parti pour
faire un un petit livre. On pensait
faire un livre de 150000 signes, 100
pages parce que pour voir un petit peu
faire un état des lieux en fait et en
pensant qu'il y avait pas forcément
énormément de choses à dire.
[grognement]
Et puis en en grattant, ben j'ai j'ai vu
des trucs ben sur internet hein. Au
début, je suis resté en plus c'était le
confinement à l'époque encore déjà.
et et je suis notamment tombé sur un
site qui est le site de l'association
américaine qui s'appelle USRTK
qui
qui veut dire quoi RT
US right to know qui qui libère de
l'information un peu c'est on peut dire
un peu des lanceurs d'alerte mais qui
qui qui qui ont sorti des choses
intéressantes notamment sur les
les OGM ou ce genre de choses et et là
ils avaient une page genre consacrée à
ça où je suis tombé sur je sais pas 50
60 100 papiers des articles de presse ou
des publications scientifiques
et qui traitait de bah notamment de
cette hypothèse du laboratoire avec une
masse d'information énorme et qui
n'avait absolument pas filtré en France
quoi. En fait, on avait il y avait rien
dans la presse française de tout ce que
je découvrais sur ce truc là.
Le ce site internet RTK là, c'est quoi ?
Qu'est-ce qui est derrière ? Qu'est-ce
qui fait ça ? Depuis combien d'années
ils font ça ?
C'est une ONG qui je sais pas s'ils ont
peut-être une dizaine d'années. Moi je
les connaissais pas avant et je vous
dis, ils ont sorti des trucs et ils
utilisent beaucoup en fait
là c'était la collecte de d'Aric donc ça
c'était pas vraiment leur travail mais
par contre eux leur truc c'est de
récupérer des [grognement]
des données, des conversations
essentiellement en récupérant des mails.
Euh
tu récupères comment ? par le droit
américain à l'accès aux données et du
coup il chopent des informations assez
confidentielles et ils ont ils ont fait
trois quatre histoires. Je dis un truc
sur les OGM. Après, j'ai pas exploré
plus
mais avec en divulguant ces infos, ils
ont ils avaient ils ont fait des grosses
affaires aux États-Unis et là ils en ont
vite fait une quand j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser sur le truc sur
les mails de celui qui est en fait
l'expert un peu number one de l'origine
du virus à la fois pour le landet
et à l'OMS et même pour d'autres
associations
comment s'appelle
s'appelle Peter d'Azac
et qui montrait qu'en fait ben
on part tout de suite là-dessus mais que
bah c'est quelqu'un qui a qui a pas mal
manigancé pour pour exclure l'hypothèse
du laboratoire.
Manigan pourquoi ? C'est c'est gratuit
ce que pourquoi on dit manigan ? Il a
intrigué.
On peut dire qu'il a un peu intrigué
parce qu'en fait c'est quelqu'un qui a
une ONG donc qui s'occupe de de
collecter des virus dans le monde pour
prévenir les pandémies.
et qui travaille avec différents
laboratoires dont l'Institut de
virologie de Wan avec lequel il bosse
sur les coronavirus et euh et notamment
sur l'évolution que pourraient avoir les
coronavirus
en faisant des ce qu'on appelle des
gains de fonction de de booster un peu
l'évolution des virus. Et donc cette
personne qui est quand même assez proche
du laboratoire qui pourrait être le
premier qu'on regarderait en cas de
fuite de de bah de lab
et ben c'est lui qui a quand je vous dis
qu'il a manigancé c'est qu'il a il a
écrit une tribune qui était destinée qui
a été publiée dans le land 7 euh dans
laquelle il il assimile en fait
l'hypothèse d'une fuite à une théorie du
complot qui doit être écartée en tant
que tel quoi.
Et ce qui a révélétt
par dans le land 7 était signée par 27
scientifique assez renommé.
Lui, il apparaît dedans mais comme un
par les 27 et on voit pas du tout qu'en
fait c'est lui qui a écrit cette
tribune. Mais USRTK a divulgué des mails
où on le voit qui qui contactent les
premières personnes en disant il faut
que il faut qu'on défende les gens avec
qui on travaille et il faut pas que ça
apparaisse comme ma tribune ou comme
celle de son association qui s'appelle
Alliance mais comme une tribune de
scientifiqu
et et donc voilà et c'est passé et ce
papiers est paru dans le land 7 je crois
que c'était le 19 février une douzaine
de jours après qu'il envoie ses mail et
ça a fait euh ça a eu un impact dans le
monde entier et c'est à partir de ce
moment-là en fait que
dans la communauté scientifique mais
aussi dans les médias on a pris un peu
pour argent content ce que racontait
cette tribune et donc il était il est
devenu [grognement] exclu de d'envisager
cette hypothèse. D'autant plus que de
mois après, il y a Donald Trump qui se
l'a accaparé et du coup bah Donald Trump
a pas une grande côte et il a il a aussi
dit beaucoup de choses excessives et
donc voilà, c'était c'était discrédité
et en fait la la tribune enfin c'est
l'interview d'Étienne de Croly à
l'automne dernier. Ça a remis dans le
jeu un peu l'hypothèse du labo par un
par un scientifique installé qui est
dans un laboratoire tout à fait. Il y a
sous l'administration Biden, il y a
quand même euh le gouvernement américain
qui a émis quelques réserves concernant
les les origines du virus et ils disent
que il ne faut pas retirer des
hypothèses une fuite de labour.
Ah bah le gouvernement Biden, oui, il
est il a
il va là-dedans. Bah surtout c'est c'est
en rapport avec le la mission de l'OMS
avec la Chine qui a eu lieu au mois de
février. Et donc le le gouvernement
Biden, il est pas très satisfait de
de de cette mission et en tout cas, il
trouve qu'elle est pas suffisante et
notamment parce que cette hypothèse n'a
pas été explorée.
Donc il y a les Américains avec 13
autres pays dont Israël, la
Grande-Bretagne, le Canada, l'Australie,
la Norvège et puis je ne sais plus,
[souffle coupé] on on demandait d'aller
plus loin en fait. Et c'est vrai que
l'année dernière, c'était un peu réservé
à Trump avec ce que ça comporte, c'est
ce que ça implique, mais beaucoup
pensaient que quand Trump partirait,
les Américains lâcheraient l'affaire,
mais c'est pas le cas en fait.
Alors, qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui vous
permet
après ce ce livre et cette enquête de
dire qu'il y a quand même un faisceau de
présemption un faisceau de preuve qui
qui pourrait indiquer une piste sérieuse
?
Bah déjà les pistes sérieuses, il y en a
plusieurs. Il y a pas moi j'aborde pas
que la question du
[raclement de gorge]
du laboratoire dans
pas que ce sujet là.
Moi non, moi c'est on fait tout. Alors,
c'est vrai que la piste du laboratoire,
elle est pas mal explorée parce que bah
parce que déjà quand j'ai commencé, ben
elle était pas du tout elle l'était pas
du tout. Donc donc c'était intéressant
mais il y a il y a d'autres choses parce
que on est on est vite parti en fait sur
une idée que ça provient de la faune
sauvage, le pangolin qui était un peu
une un compte moral presque parce que
c'était le petit animal qui est le plus
braconné au monde que qu'on donc qu'on a
maltraité et qui qui se venge. C'est la
nature qui se venge par l'intermédiaire
du pangolin.
Alors qu'en fait des des pistes même
d'élevage en fait sont beaucoup plus
probables parce que les la plupart des
épidémies qui émergent des maladies des
maladies infectieuses qui émergent
passent plutôt par des élevages que
directement la viande de brousse on
interdit on est en train d'interdire le
commerce de la viande de la viande
sauvage de de la faune sauvage. Mais
mais quand on regarde en fait le passage
direct de la faune sauvage à l'homme
c'est très rare quoi. Et et là le
pangolin, bah c'est aussi une opération
qui a été
peu orchestrée par la Chine
avec des données qui au départ étai avec
des informations qui étaient un peu
mensongères.
Quel type ? Bah, il y a une il y a eu
une conférence de presse qui a été faite
début février par la [grognement]
l'université de Chine du Sud qui a
présenté qui a dit qu'elle avait trouvé
des virus de coronavirus chez les
pangolins.
Faut pas que je balance mon pied. Euh
avec une identité génétique de 99 % par
rapport à Sarscov 2. Et ça 99 % c'est le
c'est c'est l'étape avant enfin c'est
qu'on attend de l'aute intermédiaire du
dernier échelon animal avant l'homme
quoi. Et ça ça a été repris
immédiatement dans nature euh et ça a
fait le tour du monde alors qu'en fait
il s'avère que l'identité des virus de
pangolin, elle est de 90 %.
Et donc là, on n plus du tout dans la
proximité de d'un autre intermédiaire
et qu'il y a une zone de ces virus qui
elle est à 97 % et qui est une zone
importante parce que c'est la zone le
domaine de liaison de [grognement] du
virus avec les cellules humaines.
Mais donc ça c'est a cette histoire qui
s'est beaucoup qui s'est répandu comme
un comme traîné de poudre et qui a mis
cette image qui est qui est encore à
l'automne même encore là je voyais une
semaine suré il y avait un documentaire
coronavirus c'est le pangolin la faune
sauvage c'est ça qui qui explique la
l'épidémie
est-ce que vous avez un background
scientifique
bah moi je suis juriste de formation
donc c'est pas vraiment scientifique
mais par contre j'ai j'aime bien Euh
j'ai prêté pas mal de sujets
scientifiques et notamment avec Marianne
avec qui je bosse depuis quelques
années, je fais pas mal de papiers
scientifiques. Ouais.
Est-ce qu'il y a une incurie ? Est-ce
qu'il y a pas une incurie ? Est-ce qu'il
y a une ignorance
dans la presse française sur les
questions scientifiques ?
Une ignorance.
Je ne sais pas ce qu'on peut dire ça
là. Moi je vois pas mal de suiviste avec
du suivisme avec avec ça. Alors est-ce
que c'est une ignorance ? Moi, je veux
pas cataloguer la presse française
ignorante, mais sur ce sujet comme dans
d'autres, il peut y avoir des préjugés
ou de ou du suivisme, mais là, on a
beaucoup suivi Ouais. Bah, le land 7 a
dit ça donc amène quoi.
Et c'est
et ben non.
Bah non, c'est pas si simple que ça.
C'est pas si simple que ça.
Revenons à notre histoire de Pangola et
de Chine. Donc il y a il y a à votre
avis, il y a eu un
une je cherche mes mots, une un écran de
fumée de la Chine concernant le le
pangolin. C'est ça.
Bah, il y a une sorte de de diversion
hein un petit peu euh et ce qui est
intéressant, c'est que c'est pas que la
Chine parce que il y a des relais euh il
y a des relais occidentaux qui sont euh
bah un journal comme Let.
Après, vous avez des journaux comme
Neture qui ont accrédité cette thèse du
pangolin avec des des grands
scientifiques qui qui qui ont porté
cette idée qui ont nature a été très
impliquée là-dedans avec d'abord ce
relais de la conférence de presse
chinoise. Après, ils ont publié
plusieurs papiers sur l'hypothèses du
pangolin qui était moins affirmatif
parce que les données pouvaient pas,
c'était plus 99 % mais qui entretenait
quand même l'idée que ça pouvait venir
du pangolin. Nature a aussi fait un
papier qui est devenu la référence qui
qui dit que c'est forcément un virus
naturel qui exclut l'hypothèse du labo
de façon assez arbitraire en fait.
Et et ça ça a été euh ouais c'était
c'est devenu la référence qui a été
suivie un peu par tout le monde. Donc
les journalistes
ils ont fait un peu comme les autres.
[rires]
Ils ont marché en canard.
Ouais je ne sais pas si c'est en canard
ou ou en filienne
aussi. Ils peuvent marcher en canard en
filienne aussi hein.
Euh quelles sont les les autres pistes
que vous avez levé en creusant autour du
coronavirus ? Donc les les conflits
d'intérêt, ça on a fait
bah il y a des conflits d'intérêt par
exemple vous voyez les les gens qui
écrivent le papier de ce papier de
référence qui passe en nature, ce sont
des gens qui travaillent avec la Chine
déjà qui qui sont qui ont été primés,
qui ont qui sont été récompensés, qui
ont travaillé avec des universités
chinoises et c'est quand même c'est
quand même étonnant quoi. Vous avez
Peter d'Azac bah qui lui travaille aussi
beaucoup avec la Chine. Mais sinon
qu'est-ce que vous me disiez ? J'ai
zappé
sur les les conflits d'intérêts.
Bah le plus gros conflit d'intérêt,
c'est celui de Pitt Dazac. Parce que
quand vous avez quelqu'un qui est qui
qui qui passe comme l'expert numéro 1
alors qu'en fait il travaille avec le
suspect numéro 1 et qu'il orchestre
une espèce de stratégie pour pour
écarter une piste
et et ça c'est ça s'est passé même
encore il est pas il est même pas du
tout discret d'ailleurs parce que USRTK
a sorti ses mails au mois de novembre
qui eu beaucoup moins d'impact
d'ailleurs. J'en discuté avec le mec que
que les choses qu'ils avaient fait
auparavant sur les OGM ou sur d'autres
scandales qui avaient eu un
retentissement celui-ci n'a pas eu un
gros un énorme retentissement mais ça
c'était quand même connu quoi à partir
de ce moment-là et quand il y avait la
mission de l'OMS à
Peter d'Azac aurait pu se faire discret
comme la plupart des des experts de
l'OMS que qu'on voyait pas qui répondait
pas alors que lui il passait 14 tweets
par jour, il répondait à tous les
journaux
et et aucun journal ne mettait en avant
le fait que bah ce type était bah il
était discrédité en fait, il devrait pas
être là quoi parce que il y a un conflit
d'intérêt énorme et on lève pas beaucoup
les confér ont pas été tellement
remarqués à part aujourd'hui un peu
celui-ci mais je dis il y a un mois
quand il était à ça c'était étonné moi
de voir tous les journaux qui le citaent
à chaque fois et et pour dire que oui il
y a rien à signaler au labo quoi en
les Chinois sont transparents parce que
sa tribune, elle était quand même aussi
hallucinante. C'était
c'était quand même de dire que la Chine
était un modèle de transparence.
Donc bon, c'est
la France est bien le pays des droits de
l'homme.
Oui, peut-être. C'est vrai. Mais bon, la
Chine un modèle de transparence, ça
passe. Et quand il était à Ouan, il
disait encore "C'est génial, c'est
super, on est super bien accueilli, les
gens nous font voir tout ce qu'on veut."
Alors ça c'est vrai ou c'est pas vrai ?
l'OMS que l'enquête de l'OMS, ça a donné
quoi ? Quelle a été l'attitude du
gouvernement chinois ? Ils ont eu accès
à quoi ? Est-ce qu'ils ont pu être libre
de se balader partout ? Est-ce qu'ils
ont eu accès à toutes les souches qu'il
voulaient ? Est-ce qu'ils ont eu accès à
tous les sites qu'il voulaient ? Ou
est-ce que c'était un voyage touristique
organisé par une ambassade ? Bah c'est
moi j'ai appelé ça un peu une visite de
courtoisie dans le livre mais euh mais
ils étaient euh bah déjà il faut voir
que c'était pas une enquête et ça l'idée
générale c'était qu'ils allaient faire
une enquête mais les Chinois eux étaient
très clairs. Ce n'est pas du tout une
enquête, c'est une étude conjointe et en
fait une étude qui a été faite par la
Chine en fait toutes les données qui qui
dont disposaient don disposaient les
experts de l'OMS déjà c'était une
mission donc conjointe où il y avait 17
experts de l'OMS et 17 experts chinois
et qui tous récupéraient des données
fournies par la Chine et les experts de
l'OMS ont pu demander on veut aller voir
le marché ou qui a été beaucoup vu comme
un endroit qui é un lieu de propagation
du virus mais qui a qui a été beaucoup
vu aussi comme là où d'où il pourrait
venir
celui qui a 300 m du P3 c'est ça du
laborato
non il était pas loin du du CDC d'un
laboratoire P2 plutôt
de pas de l'Institut de virologie mais
du CDC de OAN et oui ils étudient aussi
les les chau-schouris et les coronavirus
mais euh
la Chine le gouvernement chinois
mais oui donc le gouvernement chinois
enfin les autorités chinoises ont fourni
toutes les données et les occidentaux
ont pu demander à aller voir bah les
laboratoires, le marché, ces choses là.
Donc c'est ça que disait Peter, on a pu
aller partout où on allait, sauf qu'ils
ont été mais ils ont pas inspecté. Ils
ont pas inspecté. Ils ont pas ils ont
été écouté les gens qui leur racontaient
leur ce qu'ils voulaient leur raconter
et qui leur ont montré ce qu'il
voulaient leur montrer.
[grognement] Magnifique.
Euh
est-ce qu'ils ont été se baladés autre
part que dans le marché, dans le couloir
de l'hôtel et est-ce qu'ils ont été dans
une mine ?
Et non, ça ils ont pas été dans la
fameuse mine.
C'est quoi cette fameuse mine ?
Et ben c'est une mine euh dans laquelle
euh en 2012, c'est une mine qui est dans
le Yunan qui est donc une province du
sud de la Chine,
1500 km de W
à peu près. Ouais. Dans cette province,
c'est là qu'on avait déjà trouvé les
chauves-souris euh qui étaient à
l'origine de de du premier SARS en 2002
2003.
Vous voyez pas ce premier SARS, c'est la
première épidémie de SARS, SARSCOV 1. Et
et donc depuis ce moment-là, on sait que
bah les chauves-souris sont les le
réservoir naturel de des coronavirus.
Le chameau aussi, le lama.
Non, le le dromadaire a été
l'intermédiaire pour l'épidémie suivante
qui était celle du MERS, mais ça venait
aussi des chauves-souris. Alors, j'en
profite, j'en profite de lire un
commentaire de la communauté de Bob le
bricoleur.
Bonjour Bob. qui nous dit "Des
transmissions animal homme très rares."
Il est marrant ce monsieur. Il il est au
courant qu'avant là, il y a eu le sida,
la dingue, le chikuna, Ebola, Mers,
Sarskov 1, H5N1 H1N1
ces 30 40 dernières années. Ben
justement, vous voyez, ben Sarcov 1,
Sarskov 1, c'est
on dit que c'est la Civette qui est
passée entre justement la chauve-souris,
la Civette qui était un animal d'élevage
qui a qui a passé euh à l'homme et pour
le MER, ce qui est l'autre virus par
coronavirus, c'est passé par le
dromadaire qui est pas un animal
d'élevage mais qui est un animal
domestique qui est et c'est pas l'animal
sauvage qui a contaminé directement les
gens avec le donc voilà pour après c'est
il y a une étude qui a été faite en
20082009 pour lancer un programme qui
s'appelle Predict qui qui
qui va part à la recherche en fait des
virus pour connaître les virus avant
qu'ils arrivent. Et là, il y avait sur
340 émergences,
il y en avait quatre, il y avait un
quatre sur 340 émergences qui venaient
directement de la faune sauvage et de la
viande de brousse et ce genre de choses.
Donc les les l'élevage est beaucoup plus
ça vient au départ de d'un animal
sauvage mais ça passe par en général ça
passe par un intermédiaire d'élevage.
Donc revenons à cette fameuse mine.
Est-ce qu'on parle bien de la même de de
celle qui a créé la qui a généré la mort
de si six
c'est ça
de tr de trois mineurs ?
Il a trois qui sont morts
qui étaient qui étaient venus nettoyer
la mine.
C'est ça. C'est
Et est-ce qu'on parle bien de la même
scientifique chinoise qui était sur
place qui a fait les prélèvements qui
les a ramené à
bah ça c'est la c'est pas la directrice
du wif mais c'est la chercheuse un peu
vedette du de l'Institut de virologie de
Wan.
Comment elle s'appelle ? qui s'appelle
Zengishi ou Shi Zengli suivant comment
dans le sens mais moi j'ai mis Zengishi
mais elle oui et c'est elle qui a
d'ailleurs à l'époque du SARS dans les
années 2000 qui a découvrir qui a qui a
amené sur la piste des qui a trouvé que
c'était ça venait d'une chauve-souris à
l'origine quoi. Donc elle est devenue la
spécialiste mondiale des virus des
coronavirus qu'on trouve chez les
chauve-souris. Elle elle est surnommée
Bat Woman parce qu'elle elle a organisé
énormément d'expéditions en général dans
cette zone là dans le sud dans le Yunan
ou dans le sud de la Chine. Et euh et
elle était effectivement allée avec ses
équipes à plusieurs reprises dans cette
mine où en 2012 euh il y avait des
mineurs qui travaillaient à la nettoyer.
Pendant pendant 15 jours. Ils ont passé
il y en avait quatre qui ont passé
pendant 15 jours et deux qui ont été
pendant 4 ou 5 jours.
10 12h par jour à enlever le le Ouais à
la chinoise
et ils ont tous chopé bah une maladie
qui euh qui est qui ressemblait qui a
ressemblé en fait fortement avec aux
symptômes dont les symptômes
ressemblaient fortement au ceux des cas
graves du Covid-19
et c'est dans cette mine
qui a été trouvée parce que donc après
cette expérience enfin après cette
histoire qui a été suivi en fait par les
les plus grands virologues pneumologues
de Chine. Ça on l'a su après mais
peut-être qu'on reviendra dessus sur
grâce à un groupe qui s'appelle
Drastique qui a qui a levé beaucoup de
d'informations sur cette histoire.
Quand vous écrivez drastique ?
drastique, c'est D R A S T I K, ça veut
dire decentralize,
euh radical autonomous,
euh
search team investigation euh
investigating euh Covid-19.
Et donc un membre de Drastique dans
Graxic c'est une vingtaine de personnes.
Il y a des il y a des scientifiques
professionnels, il y a des gens qui sont
sous pseudo et qui lèvent des histoires
en fait qui qui trouve des documents et
notamment il y en a un qui a trouvé à
mémoire de
de maîtrise de de médecine
euh qui traitait du cas de ces mineurs
et qui montrait qu'ils avaient été
suivis par je crois que c'est Zan
qui est le premier le plus grand
pneumologue de Chine qui était celui qui
a qui qui a travaillé le plus sur
l'expert numéro 1 pour le SARS et pour
le SARS 2 aussi et qui a suivi ça et qui
avait diagnostiqué euh un virus
probablement de coronavirus,
une pneumonie atypique,
une pneumonie atypique qui venait
probablement d'origine virale et
et donc c'est et alors il a d'ailleurs
envoyé des des échantillons ont été
envoyés au pour analyse.
des échantillons qui ont trouvé qu'il y
avait des anticorps de de coronavirus.
Et
et un an après
cette mes aventures au mineur dont trois
sont morts,
les équipes de Zengishiy ont trouvé
parmi les virus un virus qui qui s'est
avéré en 2020 le plus proche de SARSCOV
2.
À combien de pourcent ?
À 96 %.
96 c'est très éloigné quand même.
C'est c'est le plus proche mais c'est
c'est pas géniteur direct, ça c'est sûr.
Oui, parce qu'il faut 99.
Donc je vais je vais je vais résumer
trivialement la chose et je vais me
faire l'avocat du diable. Donc on a un
scientifique américain qui est
spécialisé dans l'ajout de fonction sur
les coronavirus. Vous m'arrêtez si je me
trompe ? He
pas il est spécialisé dans la recherche
de virus et dans leur étude.
D'accord. euh qui travaille avec une
doctoresse chinoise spécialisée dans les
coronavirus surnommé Batgirl Batman
Batman
qui a analysé euh en 2013 un truc 96 %
aussi proche que ce qu'on se tape en
2019 coronavirus 19 et elle a bien
cartographié ça dans une base de
données. Et la question que je vais vous
poser mais où est cette base de données
? Elle a disparu ? Elle a pas disparu ?
Elle est toujours en ligne ? Elle est
plus en ligne ? Est-ce qu'ils ont fait
le ménage ?
La base de du Ben oui, elle est elle est
hors ligne, on va dire. Elle est
comme ça. Elle est en ligne depuis 10
ans ou récemment ?
Non, elle est en ligne depuis le 12
septembre 2019.
Oh !
Et sans sans explication. Alors,
Zengishiy a répondu à un mec, donc ça
c'est aussi un document sorti par
Drastique par un mec, je crois que
s'appelle Tom Clairry qui est c'était
rare. C'était au début de mois de
janvier je crois 2020 euh parce que
Zengier difficilement, elle m'a jamais
répondu quoi. Répond pas souvent je
crois.
Les chinois, ils répondent pas. Ouais.
Les Chinois ne m'ont pas répondu
d'ailleurs de façon assez générale, mais
là, elle avait répondu à ce type qui lui
demandait euh pourquoi la base de
données euh était était hors ligne.
Elle lui a dit que elle avait été
attaquée euh pendant l'épidémie,
sauf que en fait, elle a été enlevée,
elle a été mise en ligne en en
septembre. Donc c'était 3 4 mois avant
que avant que on connaisse
SARSCOV 2 et et ses effets.
Donc donc voilà et ça c'est une question
par exemple qui n'a pas été bien traitée
on va dire par la mission de l'OMS qui
qui évacue en fait le le rapport OMS
Chine. Donc c'est pas un rapport de
l'OMS faut bien comprendre ça. un
rapport OMS Chine donc qui est validé
par la Chine et qui évacue dans le
rapport la question du laboratoire en
une page
très expéditive alors que le rapport
fait 120 pages et qui traite un petit
peu le truc dans ses annexes ou dans les
annexes. Il parle de d'une rumeur comme
quoi la la base de données serait pas
qui aurait une base de données en ligne.
qui parle d'un tableur d'un tableur
Excel qui en fait aurait été attaqué
en fait un tableur Excel c'est 15 bases
de données qui sont très importantes et
justement les genses drastiques aussi
ont fait un détail très précis parce que
on peut on pouvait récupérer des avec la
mémoire du web on va dire on pouvait
récupérer des choses et il y avait aussi
un site un site chinois qui recensait
des bases de données où il y avait des
descriptifs
qui lui a était accessible. que donc il
y avait que le descriptif, il y avait
pas le contenu mais qui lui été
acceptible jusqu'au printemps 2020 et
qui a été mis en ligne et qui est
toujours hors ligne aujourd'hui. Et donc
ça c'est bah ça c'est pas du tout ça pas
du tout été investigué par ils ont pris
ils ont dit ils ont cru voilà le tableur
Excel qui qui a été attaqué par des
hackurs et donc on le met pas alors que
d'ailleurs un un institut comme ça ils
savent aussi se protéger théoriquement
contre des attaques. Vous connaissez ça
mieux que moi mais je pense que ils sont
pointus les et en tout cas cette base de
données n'est pas là et il y a des
centaines de de séquences de virus et
notamment
celui de 2013.
Celui de 2013, on a la séquence
puisqu'elle a été présentée
en intégralité.
Elle a été présentée en intégralité euh
mais oui, elle a été présentée mais
alors il y a pas la matière première
aujourd'hui. Ils disent qu'ils n'ont
plus la matière première et les gens qui
essayent de le reconstituer ont du mal
en fait à reconstituer la séquence
entière.
Mais ils ont aussi euh et ça l'a ils
l'ont avoué en fait
9 mois après un premier papier qui a été
publié
début février qui a été enfin publié en
janvier et publié dans nature début
février qui présentait 13 ce virus comme
le plus proche par an de Sarscov 2 et
sans trop dire d'où il venait quoi en
fait en disant qu'il venait du duunan
sans dire plus quoi, sans parler de la
mine que c'était une mine où il y avait
des gens qui avaient une pneumonie
atypique et tout ça.
Et et donc après par drastique, il y a
eu un papier qui a sorti cette histoire
de la mine par
notamment un mec de drastique qui a qui
a sorti le mémoire et après deux un
couple d'indiens de biologistes indiens
qui ont fait tout un rapport tout un
papier qui a été publié dans une revue
scientifique
et qui donc a mis un peu cette mine en
lumière et donc 9 mois après son premier
papier, Zengich et l'équipe du WI ont
fait un adin d'homme à leur article où
ils ont reconnu qu'il venaient de de ces
cette mine et que dans cette mine avait
été récupéré notamment h betta
coronavirus de type chars
dont bah tous les gens qui s'intéressent
au ce sujet aimeraient bien connaître
l'identité et la la séquence parce que
ça serait très intéressant. On manque de
virus proche et là bah il y en a h qui
ont été trouvés au même endroit que
celui le plus proche et et on donne pas
les et on donne pas leur séquence et ils
sont sans doute dans cette base de
données qui a été mise en ligne.
C'est ballot.
C'est ballot. Oh mince ! Alors, ça doit
être leur stagiaire qui a déférencé leur
base de données.
Ah, peut-être, peut-être.
Est-ce que vous Est-ce que dans votre
bouquin vous traiter euh l'aspect euh du
traitement de la crise par la Chine, les
prémisses du déploiement des sécurités,
euh des gestes barrières en Chine, des
barres soudées aux portes des gens
pauvres pour éviter qu'ils sortent de
chez eux et l'attitude des militaires
chinois autour de ce sujet-là. Est-ce
que vous avez traité, analysé et spoté
l'activité des militaires chinois
pendant le le début de la crise, avant
et aussi avant le début de la crise ?
Bah les militaires chinois, ils ont pris
le contrôle des laboratoires de Wan au
mois de février.
Donc il y a une major qui est qui est
aussi une scientifique mais qui est
arrivé à Wan et qui qui a pris les
choses en main quoi. [grognement]
Donc voilà, l'armée
c'est proche de tout est un peu proche
du parti et les laboratoires sont aussi
proches du parti et
et c'est un fait que oui, les cette
major est venue en fait prendre les
affaires en main à Ouan
et après le la gestion on va dire
sanitaire des Chinois s'ils ont bloqué
les portes. Moi, je me suis intéressé au
virus, donc pas forcément ce que j'ai
plus vu, c'est le la façon dont les
Chinois
pendant au moins 3 semaines ont on
retardait un peu le
le fait de dire qu'en fait c'était un
virus qui était contagieux.
Je suis pas d'accord avec vous ça. Les
Chinois, les Chinois ont dit tout de
suite que c'était une vraie merde. Ah
ben non, parce qu'en fait vous avez le
l'histoire bah comme je commence un peu
le livre avec ça, mais euh
à vous avez le 30 décembre 2019 une une
euh une médecin de de l'hôpital central
de qui euh qui reçoit en fait, elle a eu
plusieurs patients depuis 15 jours qui
ont cette pneumonie pneumonie atypique
assez proche de celle des des gens de
2012 [grognement]
et de 2000 c'était 2012 2013 ils ont
trouvé le virus mais les les malades ils
étaient en 2012 et donc qui a envoyé un
échantillon un laboratoire de Pékin je
crois et elle reçoit le résultat et le
résultat c'est coronavirus de manière
évidente contagieuse de type SARS.
Donc elle elle prend peur, elle elle
commence à mettre des dire à son service
de mettre des masques et puis elle met
sur le réseau social, c'est Weathat, non
c'est je sais plus
webbou peut-être.
le réseau social chinois, elle elle
publie le rapport d'analyse.
Ensuite, il y a un autre médecin,
Lian mince, le nom m'échappe aussi, mais
qui est devenu connu parce qu'il est
décédé qui qui rela ce message aussi sur
les réseaux sociaux en disant qu'il y a
des il y a des coronavirus, il y a des
malades de de coronavirus de SARS
et
et elle va se faire réprimander comme
c'est pas possible par ses chefs et lui
il va être avec d'autres arrêtés par la
police pour leur dire qu'il il
colleporte des fausses rumeurs et en
fait Le même jour, vous avez le
laboratoire de l'Institut de Volid One
qui reçoit aussi des échantillons avec
des du coronavirus de cette nouvelle
pneumonie.
À ce moment-là, la Zengishi donc Bat
Woman se trouve à Shanghai pour une
conférence. sa sa directrice l'appelle,
lui dit "Tu reviens immédiatement, il
faut que tu t'occupes de ça."
Le même jour, sur ce site là que je vous
disais qui décrivait la les bases de
données de du WIV et d'autres et
d'autres instituts chinois,
elle l'a modifié, elle l'actualise,
enfin c'est elle qui est
l'administrative. Donc je supposer que
c'est elle qui l' administr qui l'a qui
l'a changé en prenant le train en
revenant à Wan enlevant en remplaçant
faune sauvage par rodeur et et
chauve-souris
peut-être pour pas faire un lien avec la
faune sauvage qui était vendue au marché
parce que les les beaucoup de malades
qui arrivent à l'hôpital venaient du
marché de Wan.
Donc elle elle arrive là-bas et elle
reçoit le le elle a les les échantillons
de virus. elle va d'avir elle avait
entamé la le séquençage du virus et en
fait ce séquençage donc il a dû être
fait apparemment il a été fait le 2 le 2
janvier mais il a pas été communiqué le
2 janvier.
Pourquoi vous dites apparemment ? parce
qu'on a des euh des elle l'a dit à
quelqu'un et euh et qu'en plus euh un
séquençage ne prend pas beaucoup plus de
temps. Et d'ailleurs, il y a un autre
Chinois qui va qui va recevoir un un
échantillon lui le 5 le 5 janvier et qui
en 40h le séquence et qui alerte les et
qui voit qu'il est à 80 % comme le SARS
1 donc qui pense qu'il est dangereux,
qu'il est contagieux et euh et donc il
alerte les autorités et les autorités
lui
retardent elles retardent le fait de
dire en fait que le virus est contagieux
qui se transmet il laisse courir l'idée
que Ça ça passe de l'animal à l'homme
mais pas de l'homme à homme. Ce qui est
le cas en fait de la la plupart des
émergences et c'est d'ailleurs le cas
avec les ces mineurs. Ces mineurs ils
avaient sans doute pas c'était pas le
SARSCOV 2 qu'ils ont eu mais eux ils
avaient un truc qui apparemment il y a
pas eu de contagion. [grognement] Donc
les autorités chinoises laissent penser
ça jusqu'au jusqu'au 20 janvier en fait.
Mais mais ce ce cet autre cet autre
virologue chinois qui il alerte les
gens, il va à Wan le 9, il d avec des
autorité sanitaires, il leur dit ça mais
elle mouffe pas. Et et le lendemain, il
a un virologue australien qui avec qui
qui travaille beaucoup avec les Chinois
qui lui dit "Est-ce que je peux publier
le génome ?" et et il publie le génome
et il hésite un peu puis il lui dit
"Oui, allez, OK."
Et et là, il s'apprêtait à se rendre à
Pékin peut-être pour pour aller voir
encore des autorités.
[grognement]
Et et quand il arrive à Pékin, le le
l'australien a publié le génome et ça
fait la une des médias
et là bah ça va accélérer en fait la
diffusion du génome, mais les Chinois
ont quand même commencé par faire fermer
son laboratoire au mec euh pour en
faisant une inspection, disant comme si
son truc pouvait être un peu frauduleux
et parce qu'il voulait que ça soit
Zengishiy et le wif qui publie le
le génome qui va donc être publié le 12
janvier. Donc ils ont quand même attendu
10 jours
pour publier ce génome.
Est-ce que vous avez vu des mouvements
de militaire autour du mois d'octobre
des militaires chinois
octobre 2019 ? Non,
jamais
pas. Vous êtes pas intéressé à ça.
Il y a il y a il y aurait eu
[grognement] une baisse d'activité de
téléphone au
comme s'ils étaient pas là pendant 2
semaines.
Au mois d'octobre.
Mais
creuse un peu ce sujet là. Là, non.
Bah c'est ça, on le sait pas parce que
il ne parle pas. Donc on peut juste
qu'il y a eu des qu'on constatait que
les au niveau des téléphones portables
ça n'avait pas fonctionné pendant 2
semaines comme
au mois d'octobre. Et ça c'est après
aussi bah c'est une hypothèse hein que
que la fermeture de la base de données
ça soit suite à un accident en fait
et que et qu'après il y a il y a aussi
des des rumeurs là c'est plus de ça
relève plus de la rumeur que des mais
bon c'est une rumeur qui colportée par
les les le département d'état américain
qui a quand même
qu' a quand même écrit
les armes de destruction massive chez
Saddam Husin toujours. Donc c'est pas ça
ça reste quand même de la rumeur mais
qu'il y a des employés du WI qui ont été
malades
avec des pneumonies, le genre d'œuvre ou
de pneumonies ou des ou des grippes ou
des des maladies un peu qui peuvent
ressembler quand ça ?
À l'automne 2019.
Quand les quand quand les Chinois disent
que rétorque au français [soupir]
Oui, mais on on a eu des échantillons de
pipi français de 2019, de novembre, il y
avait déjà du coronavirus dedans.
De novembre ? Oui, de novembre.
Et ben ça collerait avec une diffusion
du virus en septembre quoi. Et et parce
qu'il y en a Oui, il y en a en Italie
aussi.
Alors, en Italie, c'est différent. Il y
a des élevages de vison. Mais on va
revenir sur les
Non non non. En Italie c'est pas des
élevages de vison. Il y a des il y a eu
des mais c'est pas forcément
irréprochable quoi comme étude mais il y
a eu des aussi on a trouvé des traces de
Sarscov 2 ou d'anticorps sur des
analyses de gens qui étaient dans un
essai clinique sur le cancer. Donc ça
c'est ce que les les Chinois mettent
beaucoup en avant c'est ces signes pour
dire que ça vient de l'étranger en fait.
Alors que bon ben il y a il y a peu de
signe convaincant et surtout il y a pas
de malade. Il y a pas de parce que quand
le coronavirus arrive à one
ça notamment quand il est repéré au mois
de décembre après ça va très vite quoi.
Et il y a énormément de gens qui sont
contaminés.
Alors quand vous dites ça va très vite
notre ambassadeur qu'on rémunère
grassement
en Chine a prévenu l'état l'État
français le 30 décembre.
Bah l'ambassadeur a préfons Jord c'est
c'est l'OMS qui a été prévenu le 31
décembre je crois.
Nous nous on a été on a été prévenu le
31 aussi dans peut-être
je sais pas c'est on m'a dit ça mais
j'ai pas vu d' ce truc de l'ambassadeur
qui prévient le 30 décembre. Je sais pas
d'où ça vient mais c'est officiellement
la Chine annonce et l'OMS le le
répercute le 31 décembre. En tant que
journaliste, vous trouvez que l'État
français a bien réagi rapidement
comme comme une épée bien affutée ou
comme un couteau à beurre qu'on utilise
pour tourner des vis
comme quelqu'un qui avait la tête
ailleurs plutôt et notamment parce que
bah des virologues de Marseille dont
Étienne de Croly ont trouvé tout de
suite en fait dès que
a publié le le génome là le 12 le 12
janvier
Ils l'ont observé et ils ont tout de
suite vu que ce génome, il avait une
particularité euh ce qu'on appelle un
cit furine en fait le le coronavirus
donc a une protéine spike ce qui est
quand on voit c'est les petites pointes
qu'il a. On voit le virus, il a des
petites pointes. On a vu souvent
l'image. La petite pointe c'est la
protéine spike qui va permettre de se
fixer sur la cellule. Et à mi-chemin de
cette protéine spike, il y a elle est
divisée en S1 et S2. Il y a euh
[grognement] ce qu'on appelle bah le bah
le clivage entre les deux entre les deux
euh les deux parties de la de la
protéine spike. Et là, ils ont vu qu'il
y avait ce qu'on appelle un site de
clivage à la furine qui est des acides
aminés basiques
qui contient des acides aminés basiques
et qui en fait Étienne de Crolie est un
peu un spécialiste de ce genre de de
site parce que c'est connu chez les
virus et c'est ce qui permet
de faciliter l'entrée en fait dans la
cellule et en gros on peut résumer ça
c'est un peu l'arme l'arme fatale de
Sarscov 2 quoi. celle qui lui permet
d'être très efficace et de d'avoir un
grand pouvoir un grand pouvoir de
contagosité. Pour
pour délier un peu tout ça, donc les
anciens coronavirus qu'on s'est tapé
dans l'histoire n'avait la capacité que
de passer par les cellules pulmonaires
de la gorge du nez, de la zone ORL.
C'est ça. Et là, le nouveau de la
version 2019 a les capacités d'infecter
tous les tissus du corps humain.
C'est ce qu'on constate. Il va il se
contente pas des poumons et c'est
probablement dû à ce à ce site furine
qui lui permet en fait de se fondre avec
la cellule.
Ça ça fait ça fait cliver la ça fait
cliver la le virus et ce qui lui permet
de se fondre avec la cellule et donc
d'être beaucoup plus contagieux en fait
et d'aller oui en on le repère dans des
organes jusqu'au cerveau en fait qui ce
qui explique la perte de goût et
d'odorat.
Tron cérébral, perte de goût, perte
d'odorat. D'ailleurs, prémise des des
signaux de Parkinson. Euh euh
perte d'autres choses.
On a on a noté quoi ? le tron cérébral,
le foie, l'estomac,
la peau, les yeux, la totale.
Ah, ça peut aller un peu un peu partout.
Après, moi je suis pas médecin, je suis
pas non plus
spécialiste.
Donc l'état français a réagi comme un
coup.
Mais ce qu'il y a, c'est qu'en fait donc
je vous dis, il trouve ça, il voit que
il y a ce site Flurine.
Ça c'était quand ça ?
Dès qu' dès le 12 janvier, il le voit.
il le voit tout de suite parce que c'est
quelque chose qui est assez connu mais
ce qui les étonne c'est qu'en fait c'est
la première fois qu'on voit un site
furine sur un virus SARS un coronavirus
de type SARS et donc ben Ken de Chrolie
il voit ça il dit ou là c'est pas bon
quoi. C'est ça sent pas bon ce trucl.
Et ce qui les a aussi beaucoup intrigué,
c'est que quand
Zengishi fait son premier papier où elle
présente RATG13, le virus le plus
proche, donc elle fait une révélation en
disant "Oui, on a un virus qui est on a
trouvé le virus le plus proche, il vient
des chauve-souris. Donc probablement
Sarcovient aussi des chauve-souris."
Elle compare les génomes de de RATG13 et
de SARSCOV 2,
mais elle arrête la comparaison juste
avant le site Furine et elle ne le
mentionne pas dans le papier qui va
paraître dans nature. Donc ouais [rires]
et donc c'est quand même aussi étonnant
de le la particularité le truc le plus
apparemment qui pourrait être le plus
dangereux dans ce virus. Bah, il est pas
mentionné là-dedans. Mais bon, les
Marseillais, eux l'ont bien vu comme
beaucoup d'autres, mais ils vont être
les premiers à publier un papier début
février sur ce site Furine en en
expliquant bah que c'est que c'est
étonnant qu'il soit là, que c'est la
première fois qu'on envoie un.
Je peux vous couper ? Donc ça c'était au
mois de février, mais c'était avant ou
après que notre président nous demande
d'aller au théâtre ?
C'était avant justement, c'était c'était
bien avant. Et et ce qu'on peut voir,
c'est que leur leur papier n'a eu aucun
écho. Euh ils ont fait une un communiqué
de presse qui a été repris par personne.
Les la l'information aurait pu remonter
parce que c'est des chercheurs français.
Et mais à l'époque ce qui ce qui
intéressait beaucoup les gens, c'était
Benjamin Griveau et et ses ses vidéos
intimes. Mais ça intéressait beaucoup
plus que que des Français qui ont trouvé
le truc qui pourrait craindre sur ce
virus. C'est en fait c'est là où les les
Français et les occidentaux plus
largement
on peut reprocher à la Chine d'avoir en
fait ils ont attendu 3 semaines pour
reconnaître la contagiosité
mais une fois qu'il la reconnaissent
après ils confineent one donc on voit
que ça rigole pas quoi que ils prennent
les choses en main et alors que les
occidentaux Oui.
Pourquoi vous dites les français les
occidentaux ?
Parce que les anglais fait un peu
pareil. Non, il faut dire les officiels,
les gouvernements.
Oui. Les autorités occidentales,
autorités, le peuple, le peuple français
expatrié à Onean nous a tenu
parfaitement au courant de la merde qui
se passait là-bas et dans des
proportions.
Ah oui, oui, sans doute. Ouais.
Donc, revenons à notre question. le
gouvernement français, ce couteau à
beurre sur pays à pas faire grand-chose
qui nous demande d'aller au théâtre
alors qu'il y a un grand chercheur
français qui est en train de nous
expliquer que ce fameux virus a le passe
partout pour venir nous infecter
n'importe quel centimètre carré de notre
corps et nous on va au théâtre. Donc ça
bon
bah c'est ce qu'il dit. Je crois que
c'est le le 12 12 mars
ou enfin au mois de mars quoi. Et la
veille la veille où il dit ça il y a 150
morts en Italie. Donc
non, ça a pas été pris. Là, il y a Serge
Morand, un un scientifique qui lui vit
en Thaïlande et qui s'intéresse beaucoup
aux que j'ai pas mal interrogé pour le
bouquin et qui fait même la post face me
disait lui il est revenu à Paris en fin
février, il hallucinait quoi parce que
il arrivéit de Thaïlande où tout le
monde était masqué et il arrive à Rassi,
il a rien quoi. Mais c'est il a dit
c'est un gouvernement d'irespons dans un
pays avec un gouvernement
d'irresponsable parce qu'il y a aucune
mesure de sécurité.
fin février, donc un mois et demi après
que Wan soit confiné, un mois après que
des chercheurs français alertés sur le
danger de ce virus.
Rappelez-moi, il y a combien d'habitants
à Ouan ?
11 millions.
Une broutille.
Une broutille,
hein.
Et qui ont bah qui ont essé d'ailleurs,
il y a une vingtaine de pays qui sont
qui sont les premiers enfin le les
premiers contaminations qui repèrent,
ils viennent tous de Ouan.
Donc c'est là où ça ça vient quand même
plutôt de là-bas parce que malgré
qu'attend à dire que
ça tendrait plutôt à venir de là-bas
parce que
bon quelles sont les autres hypothèses ?
Parce que ça n'est ça n'est pour
l'instant qu'une hypothèse
de quoi ?
Le fait que ce soit barré d'un labo.
Ah bien sûr. Ah non c'est c'est une
hypothèse qui qui peut s'expliquer. Mais
bah nous on parle pas mal dans le je
parle pas mal dans le livre de
d'hypothèque que c'est pas moi qui qui
est du tout levé. C'est c'est un mec qui
s'appelle Yann Fort qui est d'ailleurs
un sociologue qui est prof de
sociologie. Donc c'est c'est aussi
amusant parce que c'est souvent les les
grands virologues en charge
théoriquement de chercher. C'est pas
forcément eux qui ont fait avancer le
schmil blic sur cette histoire, mais lui
s'est beaucoup penché sur la question
des visons et
alors je sais pas si c'est une lui il le
voit comme une
un intermédiaire possible qu'il a amené
à l'homme mais surtout j'ai [grognement]
trouvé intéressant ce qu'il a vu sur en
fait qui aller retours qu'on qu'on pu
faire les visons entre l'homme et en
gros qui ont fait les variants. et il a
repéré notamment en Italie
que là où l'épidémie a explosé en
Lombardie, c'est une zone rurale. Donc
c'est assez étonnant parce que
normalement c'est plutôt les grandes
villes mais c'est une zone qui est qui a
une concentration d'élevage de vison en
fait.
Alors question internet. Alors je
connais pas la question mais je la pose
quand même. Bonjour. Pouvez-vous lui
demander s'il vous plaît s'il a entendu
parler de Chen Kishi et Fang Bin en
Chine ? J'espère que c'est pas une
blague. Merci beaucoup.
Shen Kishi et Fang Bing.
Oui. Shen Kishi et Fang Bin.
Non.
D'accord.
Revenons. Revenons à nos visons.
Oui. Donc bah les visons ce qui est
intéressant c'est que vous avez dans
cette zone en Italie où
donc ça ça sort d'une zone rurale, Yan
Ford il voit, il fait sort une sorte de
triangle, il voit les trois villages qui
sont les plus contaminés. Enfin, les
trois villes qui sont les plus
contaminées, ça fait un triangle. Et au
milieu de ce triangle, il y a trois
élevages de vison dont le plus important
élevage d'Italie.
Et et c'est là aussi qu'on va repérer
euh ce qui est en fait un peu le premier
variant
de du du SARSCOV 2.
Et et donc il y a l'hypothèse que ce
variant en fait c'est un aller-retour
chez les visons que le vison a muté que
le virus a muté chez les visons et
revenu chez l'homme. Parce qu'on on a on
a vu aussi en au Danemark ça a été
étudié, ça a été observé ça que il y
avait des il y avait pu avoir des
contacts de l'homme au vison et qui le
virus revenait en muté. Alors, on a
souvent dit que dans le nord de dans le
nord de l'Italie, il y a eu une
émergence très forte des cas de
coronavirus parce que il y avait
beaucoup de commerce avec la Chine.
Est-ce que vous avez entendu parler de
ça ?
Bah, il y a l'éleveur principal de
Vison, lui, il commerce beaucoup avec la
Chine et avec l'Asie.
Donc et il y a des échanges d'animaux.
Il y a des échanges d'animaux avec des
étalons, des choses comme ça.
Donc oui et puis les les premiers qui
ont été repérés en Italie, les premiers
malades, c'est des gens qui venaient de
Wan. Ils ont ils ont été repérés à Rome
mais ils venaient mais ça c'était des
touristes et mais ils avaient failli
escaler à Milan.
Donc c'est possible. Après est-ce que le
vison c'est une piste ? Après faut voir
c'est est-ce qu'il y a des visons
chinois en fait ? C'est parce que Yan
Fort lui ce qui il [grognement] pousse
c'est vers la Chine. Alors et
effectivement il y a la Chine est un
très grand éleveur de vison. C'est
devenu le premier éleveur mondial de
Vison.
Et après, c'est pas forcément les les
élevages de vision sont pas forcément
dans les zones où on attendrait le plus
les chauve-souris qui ont des virus un
peu proches de SARSCOV 2, mais il y en a
qui sont pas forcément très loin et
après c'est pas forcément non plus tout
étudié
mais oui, c'est une piste le le vison et
qui est qui pourrait être ben
typiquement ça serait des chauves-souris
qui ont été défquées
dans un hangar où il y a des bisons sur
leur truc où ils mangent et Ça ça
pourrait être une ce qui ferait un autre
intermédiaire avec ces ces animaux qui
en plus sont des animaux avec un élevage
qui peut être assez intensif et
[grognement] c'est plus ça qui amène des
en général hein des
dit par élevage intensif c'est ils sont
passent toute la journée dans une toute
petite cagette où ils beignent dans leur
merde et dans leur piste toute journée
ils sont nombreux et donc ils sont
nombreux il peut y avoir je sais plus
les chiffres maisordent ils s'attaquent
et donc ils sont en contact et et c'est
un virus qui se transmet par par l'air.
Donc euh et c'est très intéressant
aéroporté quoi. C'est c'est un virus
aéroporté et et donc même des cages à
côté ça peut passer d'une cage à
l'autre.
Oui, c'est un peu comme les immeubles
dans le 19e arrondissement.
Les cages à lapin le fait que ce soit
aéroporté ça a été su quand ? Est-ce que
ça a été ça a été sous-estimé, minimisé
ou il le savait dès le départ ? Non, ça
ça a été ben comme le SARS quoi. C'est
c'est ce genre de virus et c'est ça
qu'il est rend contagieux en fait hein.
Non mais il y a par contact et il y a
aéroporté.
Il aéroporté c'estàd que les micro
guttelet
voilà c'est ça. Mais le savait dès le
départ.
Ouais on l' vi dessus ça. Oui on on l'
décit.
Bah à peu près tout de suite vous dit là
le le mec qui fait l'analyse et dit ce
truc est contagieux comme le SARS. de
SAR, c'était comme ça. Donc c'est c'est
c'est
c'est c'est vite établi, quoi.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du fait qu'on
on porte des masques dans des RER sur
sur blindé ? Est-ce que ça pose des
risques
de quoi d'être dans des ration blind ?
C'est pas le masque qui pose le risque
là. même masqué, c'estàd
Ah bah ça après je dis ça c'est pas
vraiment mon domaine mais c'est sûr que
c'est quand vous êtes dans je sais pas
il y a il y a des un peu desabérations
avec ce Covid. Moi je suis çaard vous
voyez là cet hiver on a fermé le remonté
mécanique
et donc les gens faisaient du ski en
navette.
J'habite ma famille est vers la Pagne.
Il y a des stations, il a une bas des
stations qui a 1400 m, le haut c'est à
2100 m. Il y a des navettes qui relient
toutes les stations et donc c'est entre
2100 et c'est une piste donc qui est une
assez grande piste.
Il y a un télésiège normalement mais là
le télésiège était fermé et donc les
gens faisaient quand même du ski en
prenant la navette bondée pour aller de
1400 à 200 m. Donc ça c'est un peu les
aberrations du Covid quoi. Mais mais
c'est pas c'est pas vraiment mon domaine
quoi. Je suis pas médecin. Je sais pas.
Pourquoi vous dites aéroporté ? Bon ok
vous êtes pas médecin. Vous vous avez
étudié ce que ça veut dire exactement
aéroporté. C'est aéroporté on le respire
mais aussi on se le prend par
gouttelette dans les yeux.
Aéroporté c'est le mode de transmission
le plus le plus efficace pour un virus
et et c'est ce qui est fouie. C'était le
cas pour pour le SARS et c'est le cas
pour SARSCOV 2. Et c'est aussi ce que
peuvent même rechercher dans les
laboratoires. C'est ce qui avait fait
scandale
en
2011-212. On avait fait ça avec un virus
de grippe avière qui ne se transmettait
pas entre humains et il avait été rendu
à aéroporté pour voir qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui pourrait arriver. et ça
avait amené
un peu un scandale et une polémique sur
les travaux de laboratoire parce que
faire des virus comme ça, bah ça peut
être dangereux s'il s'échappe quoi. Et
c'est un peu aussi la question que pose
que pose cette histoire de Sarscov 2
parce que les laboratoires de Oua
notamment travaillaient en fait à rendre
des virus plus dangereux, pas pour créer
des bombes, pas pour faire mal aux gens,
mais pour anticiper des mutations qui
pourraient être dangereuses. Et le
l'aéroporté, c'est une sorte de me de la
contagion, quoi.
Est-ce que est-ce que durant votre
bouquin, vous avez eu le temps
d'enquêter sur les différents variants ?
Pas du tout.
Bah ce qui ce qui est intéressant dans
le c'est qu'au début il y a pas de
variant en fait sur Sharcov 2 et c'est
une de ces caractéristiques étonnantes,
c'est que normalement un virus quand il
arrive de l'animal qu'il arrive chez
l'homme
les les premiers mois il va s'adapter à
l'homme donc il va évoluer, il va muter
pour être bah pour être plus efficace
pour s'adapter à son nouvel autre.
Et c'est ce qu'on avait observé avec le
premier SARS où pendant 3 mois, il y a
pas mal de mutations
et de mutation significative en fait qui
qui qui modifie significativement le le
virus sur des endroits clés, des
endroits qui vont lui permettre de mieux
de mieux se coller.
Et là ben ce qu'on observé plusieurs
chercheurs, c'est que notamment une
chercheuse américaine qui s'appelle
Alinachan qui est d'origine asiatique et
qui a grandi à Singapour et donc elle
avait vécu la première épidémie de SARS
et et là donc elle s'est retrouvée
confin travail à un institut qui est qui
dépend du MIT et de Harvard je crois
aussi donc un institut assez prestigieux
et elle était confinée Donc elle
s'ennuyait et elle a cherché elle elle
s'est mis à regarder à se documenter sur
sur SARSCOV 2 et sur SARS et elle a
remarqué que en fait si on prenait les
génomes des deux trois premiers mois de
de l'épidémie, il était très stable
alors que celui de 2003 il avait
beaucoup muté et ça l'a amené à comme si
ce virus avait été préparé en fait pour
être adapté à l'homme. Et donc elle a
émis cette hypothèse qui qui s'il avait
été travaillé en laboratoire pour ça et
ben ça ça pourrait s'expliquer.
Bon son papier a pas été accepté à la
publication.
On se dem pourquoi
et vous avez un autre un autre chercheur
qui lui est plus installé parce que elle
elle c'est une post doctorante donc elle
est jeune. L'autre, c'est un chercheur
qui s'appelle Nicol Petrovski qui lui
est en Australie et qui est spécialiste
des vaccins et qui dans l'hiver 2020 a
tout de suite voulu commencer à
travailler sur un vaccin et pour mieux
comprendre le virus et il l'a modélisé
pour faire son vaccin et puis il a aussi
voulu chercher de voir d'où pouvait
venir ce virus et donc il a pris une
partie du virus qui est en fait le
domaine de liaison celui qui s'accroche
à la au récepteur AS2 qui est le
récepteur qui adéquate sur la cellule
humaine à ce virus et il a voulu
regarder euh
à quel était le le SARSCOV 2 était le
plus adapté parce que il avait remarqué
que dans les précédentes épidémies quand
le virus arrive,
il est plus adapté à l'autre qui qui
vient de quitter. Donc c'était le cas
avec la Civette, c'était le cas avec le
dromadaire pour le MERS ou le SARS ou le
premier SARS. Donc il a passé en série
une revue d'animaux dont euh le pangolin
et la chauve-souris bien sûr. Est-ce
qu'il a étonné ? Bah c'est qu'en fait
non le virus il était il était le plus
adapté c'était à l'homme et et ça
c'était aussi c'était aussi curieux
parce que il s'attendait pas à ça.
C'était pas normal. Et il a aussi donc
fini son papier en disant bah ça laisse
ça laisse envisager une possibilité qui
est on pourrait le comprendre parce
qu'il aurait été travaillé en
laboratoire. En fait, il y a deux
options. C'est soit le virus a été
repéré au bout de 3 mois et il a fait
cette évolution peut-être en gagnant
d'ailleurs le site Furine parce que le
site furine a pu être acquis
naturellement,
soit ben il a été travaillé avant
et et donc par exemple avec des souris
humanisées comme en nom, on a le
laboratoire de Wan des il travaillent
avec des souris qui ont un as de humain.
Et donc si vous travaillez là-dessus,
ben ce serait pas étonnant que le virus
soit bien adapté à l'asse du humain
puisqu'il a été fait sur des souris
humanisées.
Mais c'est une hypothèse et une
hypothèse qui n'a pas été acceptée parce
que c'est ces deux personnes qu'on fait
des papiers qui sont des papiers très
intéressants parce que quoi qu'il en
soit, ils amènent des données sur la
stabilité de ce génome pendant ces
premiers premers mois de l'épidémie qui
est une donnée importante et ça a été
refusé. en tant que journaliste, le fait
que on puisse pas traiter tous les
sujets d'une façon libre, autonomo, mais
sans pression, euh voir un an après que
ceux qui avaient été catalogués comme
complotistes, bah maintenant, ils ont du
renfort auprès des autorités américaines
qui disent quand même cette hypothèse,
il faut quand même la prendre en
considération. On ne peut pas l'écarter.
Vous en tant que journaliste, le fait
qu'il y ait cette autocensure dépression
sur des sujets clés qui euh dont la
population a besoin pour pouvoir
s'informer, ça vous fait quoi
d'avoir des sujets, ils sont tellement
chauds qu'on peut pas les toucher ?
Ça arrive. Il faut un bris perrier tête
brûlée pour s'accorder "OK, je vais le
faire un bouquin dessus parce que c'est
ma c'est mon boulot, c'est mon sacerdoce
journaliste."
Bah là depuis il y a eu quand même il y
a eu de d'autres journalistes qui sont
interroés quand je
soyez pas humble comme ça. Depuis vous
étiez dans dans les premiers à vouloir
cartographier ces hypothèses.
Au départ c'était dur.
Ah bah au départ on m'a refusé les
papiers. Mais bah il y a des préjugés
quand même un peu dans la presse. C'est
il y a souvent un peu un suivisme et des
préjugés qui peuvent exister. Là il y
avait préjugés que ouais ce sujet
c'était un peu sulfureux. C'était Trump
c'était professeur Montagnier. C'était
complotistes quoi. C'est
quoi cette histoire de professeur
Montagnier là ? Et le mec qui a dit "Ah,
c'est le prix Nobel parce que il a
découvert le virus de sida qui a dit une
connerie encore à la télé comme quoi il
y avait des insertions de virus de sida
dedans."
Il a mis une hypothèse après il a pris
il a pris il avait
ça a été démenti. Il y a d'autres
chercheurs qui ont analysé le génome et
qui ont vu que
bah que ça pouvait être autre chose
parce que surtout c'était il a des c'est
des petits morceaux qui ressemblent
aussi là et qui pourrait être qui
pourrait être qui pourrai venir
d'ailleurs
et qui qui qu'on retrouve dans d'autres
virus. il en av relevé quatre et
et par exemple tienne de Croly avec
euh avec trois quatre autres personnes
ont aussi fait un papier où ils font une
étude philogénétique de du virus qui
recherche justement les origes de ces
pas des virus de ces quatre insertions
en fait. Et là ils ont trouvé que ils
ont trouvé une explication pour trois
euh qui où ils ont vu que ce virus avait
été présent. Enfin, c'est ce petit
morceau était présent chez des
chauve-souris ou chez des virus de
pangolin. Euh, mais ils ont pas trouvé
le le 4e, il est venu nulle part et le
4e c'est le site de Flurine.
Mais mais après le professeur Montagier,
il il a dit ça mais c'était une
hypothèse. Il y avait des Indiens déjà
qui l'avaient fait qui avaient mis cette
hypothèse parce
qu'il beaucoup là, c'était pas une
hypothèse.
Bah, il disait lui, il disait que
c'était c'était ce qu'il disait c'était
que c'était identique. C'était il y
avait des morceaux qui ressemblaient au
sol du sida. Donc il disait lui il pense
qu'ils ont été insérés mais c'est des
insertions après une insertion c'est une
insertion c'est une mutation donc elle
peut être naturelle ou artificielle mais
après lui même je trouve qu'on a on a
abusé un peu avec lui parce que il
disait pas que c'était un c'était un
complot que c'était volontaire lui il
parlait d'un accident et tout de suite
on a dit voilà c'est le complot c'est ça
n'a rien de complotist il disait il a
sans doute fait une erreur une erreur
d'interprétation mais mais il dénonçait
pas un complot en fait ça ça relevait
pas du complot, ça ce qui disait
relevait d'un accident.
Vous comprenez aussi cette autocensure
au doux départ de ne pas vouloir
incriminer une puissance qui devient de
plus en plus béliqueuse avec ses
congénères
pour éviter du chinois bashing.
C'est-à-dire qu'au départ, il y avait
déjà du Chinois bashing avec les Chinois
en France qui se faisait emmerder parce
que ils étaient identifiés par une
partie de la population comme eux les
porteurs ou les disséminateurs de de
virus. Est-ce que vous comprenez cette
cette réserve
d'impliquer la Chine dès le départ pour
éviter une guerre économique, que la
Chine se tende, que la Chine devienne de
plus en plus béliqueuse avec nous et que
la Chine nous dise "Bon, maintenant vos
merdes à 5 € qu'on vous a vendu pendant
des décennies pour suborder votre vote,
maintenant c'est terminé. Est-ce que il
y a eu ce ce
cette autocensure des journalistes ?
Est-ce que c'est compréhensif ? Je sais
pas si ça c'est les journalistes. Je
pense que ça c'est plus chez les euh
chez les chez les politiques
genre les par exemple Macron veut pas
chercher des soucis à la Chine. C'est
quand même un gros pays qui est très
puissant. Euh donc c'est délicat
diplomatiquement de de s'en prendre à la
Chine. Mais la question c'est pas de
s'en prendre à la Chine en même temps.
Et la question c'est de s'intéresser à à
ce virus parce que c'est important de
savoir d'où il vient parce que parce
qu'une épidémie c'est c'est on voit ce
que ça fait une pandémie et si on veut
éviter qu'il ait des nouvelles bah c'est
mieux de comprendre d'où ça vient et et
si ça vient de d'élevage là on se
focalise sur la faune sauvage on arrête
le trafic de fa sauvage mais ça c'est
très bien mais [soupir]
si c'est si ça vient d'élevage mais il
faut mieux savoir de quel élevage ça
peut venir pour bah pour sonder ça pour
repérer
Et si ça vient d'expérience menée dans
les laboratoires euh bah faut peut-être
arrêter ces expériences ou les ou les
contrôler ou les
Ouais. ou même éviter par peut-être des
choses qui sont trop risquées et donc
voilà. Donc ça c'est ça qui est très
important et c'est c'est ces questions
scientifiques en fait qui qui qui prime
selon moi. Après, je peux comprendre que
des pays soient dans des considérations
diplomatiques avec une puissance comme
la Chine.
Euh votre bouquin, il est correctement
sourcé. Vous avez mis toutes vos sources
à l'intérieur.
Bah oui.
J'ai une question sur les sources.
Euh on va prendre une question internet.
Ça alors on va le réexpliquer.
On n'est pas obligé mais bon. C'est quoi
ce récepteur humain de virus qu'il cite
? On comprend rien ce qu'il dit, ce
qu'il a dit ou il ne connaît pas. Est-ce
que vous pouvez réexpliquer le la
l'as 2 ?
Ouais. l'as de ou la furine ou la la
spike
en gros euh la donc le j'espère être
plus clair le virus donc a une protéine
qui s'appelle le spike. Elle en a plein
d'ailleurs c'est celle qui font ses
petits pics, les petits pics du
coronavirus qui lui font sa couronne. Et
dans la spike vous avez ce qui s'appelle
un domaine de liaison qui est le domaine
qui va se lier à la cellule et il a
besoin d'un récepteur. Il y a plusieurs
récepteurs sur les cellules humaines
comme sur les cellules d'animaux. Et
celui qui colle à
à
au SARSCOV 2, c'est un récepteur qui
s'appelle l'AS 2. Et donc voilà. Et si
le domaine de liaison colle avec l'AS 2
et ben vous avez contagion, vous avez
diffusion du virus.
Ah si il y avait un truc,
je sais pas, c'est plus clair.
Il fallait qu'on parle d'un truc.
Excusez-moi, je vais être obligé de
remonter. Voilà. Euh les deux les deux
prénoms et noms qu'on a cités seraient
des journalistes citoyens qui ont été
portés disparus ça fait plus d'un an
en Chine.
En Chine, ouais. Ça ça s'est beaucoup vu
pendant votre enquête des des
journalistes ou des blogueurs qui
disparaissent ?
Bah il y a eu euh des il y a eu des
celles qui s'est retrouvé en prison là
dernièrement mais il y a un livre là qui
est sorti aussi.
[grognement]
Mais les
moi j'ai pas tellement d'information.
Est-ce que vous avez reçu des menaces ?
Non.
Question internet.
Mais non.
Est-ce que vous avez des tendances
suicidaires ou des bons freins sur votre
voiture ?
Faut pas dire ça.
Alors, ce monsieur a-t-il des tendances
suicidaires et des freins parfaitement
entretenus ? A-t-il reçu des menaces ?
Pas du tout, rien. Non. On vous a
catalogué dans les salles de rédaction
comme un un mouton noir parce que vous
vous attardiez sur ce sujet-là ou pas du
tout ?
Non. Bah non. Bah de toute façon moi je
suis je suis indépendant, je suis
pigiste donc dans les salles de
rédaction j'y vais pas souvent.
Est-ce que vous êtes c'est ça c'est bien
les salles de rédaction.
Est-ce que vous êtes intéressé à la
technologie Crisp
Crisper ? Cass9.
Ouais CAS 9. [grognement]
Ben oui, bah c'est un moyen de de faire
du découpage avec mais c'est pas très
utilisé pour les coronavirus en fait.
Comment vous sourcez ça pour
Bah c'est j'en ai parlé avec Étienne de
Crolie, il y a d'autres systèmes plus
utilisés que celui-là.
Comme quoi ? comme des méthodes de
d'insertion avec des pinces moléculaires
ou des choses euh
mais enfin il m'a lui je demander
Chrisper Cas9 et pourrait être utilisé
hein pourrait être utilisé mais ne l'est
pas tellement en pratique apparemment.
Question internet. Avez-vous fait des
recherches sur les jeux militaires
internationaux qui ont eu lieu à Wan en
octobre 2019 ? E ben oui, j'ai cherché à
interviewer euh une athlète française
qui avait donné une interview où elle
disait qu'elle était malade [grognement]
et elle m'a répondu qu'elle ne parlait
plus. En fait, ils ont interdiction de
les les militaires ont eu interdiction
de parler de ça. Et il y avait eu un
papier dans le monde au printemps
là-dessus qui montrait que
il y avait bah cette cette femme qui
disait qu'elle avait été malade que son
compagnon et plusieurs membres de
l'équipe après avoir participé à ces
jeux militaires. Il y avait un italien
qui aussi dit que toute l'équipe
italienne avait été malade et qui après
les aussi bien l'armée italienne que
l'armée française leur a dit de se
taire.
Et moi j'ai contacté l'armée française
qui m'a dit en gros on avait eu aucun
cas.
Vous avez contacté l'armée française
comment ? C'est
le service communication de la
alors le numéro vert de l'armée.
Bonjour, j'ai des questions à vous
poser.
Ben voilà. Est-ce qui quelle était leur
position là-dessus ? Pourquoi est-ce que
ils m'ont pas répondu pourquoi il les
services les services de l'armée quoi.
Quel service ? C'est le ministère des
affaires étrangères, c'est le ministère
de la défense ministère de la défense.
D'accord.
Et donc il m'ont pas dit pourquoi les
soldats n'avaient pas le droit de parler
mais qu'en gros ils avaient il y avait
rien à signaler qu'ils avaient rien vu
de ni avant ni pendant ni après qu'il y
avait pas eu de malade qui avait l'air
d'avoir des des cas de Covid et que il y
avait l'armée suédoise qui aurait fait
des tests et qui n'avait rien trouvé de
convaincrant.
Donc après je sais pas et mais c'est
délicat après aussi pour eux de faire
aujourd'hui faire des tests ça serait
ça serait pas forcément faible parce que
on saurait pas quand est-ce que si les
gens ont des anticorps, on sait pas
quand est-ce qu'ils ont eu le Covid.
Donc comme énormément de gens eu le
Covid depuis, mais c'est vrai que c'est
un les jeux militaires
et d'ailleurs ce qui est amusant c'est
que c'est les c'est la Chine, les
autorités chinoises qui ont accusé les
Américains d'avoir amené le Covid
pendant les jeux militaires.
Alors un commentaire d'un de nos abonnés
qui dit "Bonjour, le génome a été publié
entre le 10 et le 11 janvier 2020 sur
virological.org.org.
Pas le 12. Donc déjà attention,
mais ça justement ça c'est euh
villorgicol.org, c'est par la
l'américain enfin l'australien qui a
publié ce trucl-là et ce qui a déplu
beaucoup à la à la Chine, c'est ce que
je vous disais là avec l'avion là, le le
mec qui prenait l'avion pour Pékin,
quand il monte dans l'avion, il donne
l'autorisation à l'australien de le
faire et quand il arrive à Pékin, ça
fait la une
et le 12, c'est officiellement par le
WIV en fait.
Alors, je termine son commentaire. En
2009, un site furine a été trouvé sur le
Sarskov 1. Donc là, il met son lien de
source. Le papier de Yugia Alina Chan ne
dit absolument pas que c'est un c'est un
fabriqué en labo, mais qui est adapté à
l'humain et qu'il pourrait y avoir des
réémergences.
C'est exactement ce que j'ai dit. Ouais.
Est-ce que cet invité a été en Chine
par-il chinois ? Et n'aurait-il pas
mieux fait de faire relire ses papiers
par des gens qui comprennent de quoi il
s'agit ? Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez lui
répondre ?
Disons [rires] que
le livre il est préfacé par Étienne de
Creli qui est un peu l'expert sur le
sujet.
Il y a pas beaucoup mieux. Euh le le
site Furine en 2009 sur SCOV 1 B je suis
sûr que non. Ou alors un monsieur a une
révélation à faire au monde he parce que
c'est que que c'est le premier virus de
type SARS qu'ils furin ça c'est un truc
à quiin et Alina Chan c'est ce que je
vous disais elle elle a pas dit que
c'était un labo. Elle a constaté qu'il
était très adapté à l'humain, d'où
suggestion est-ce que ça viendrait pas
éventuellement à laabbo ? Mais elle a
pas dit ça de façon affirmative du tout.
C'est là où c'est pas normal que ces
papiers été refusés parce que c'était
juste évoquer ça comme une éventualité
parmi d'autres.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a marqué sur l'écran ?
Activer. Ah merde, c'est parti.
Pourquoi c'est parti ?
Hop là, le passon. C'est un papier de
2009. Euh, on vous mettra le lien dans
la description.
Ah ouais, toi tu as tout fermé toi.
[rires]
Je sais pas, tu as tout fermé.
J'ai juste touché l'ordinateur sans
Revenons. Revenons à voir. Je veux bien
voir. C'est c'est quoi ce papier
?
Ça date de quand ça ? Quelle quelle
année ?
Ça date de 2009.
Ouais. Et c'est
c'est il y a pas un site furine sur le
sur le virus quoi.
Je connais pas ce papier mais
c'est écrit où ?
De quoi
le l'entête du lit du site ?
C'est PAS,
c'est la revue de l'académie des
sciences américaines.
Mais non, je connaissais pas ce papier.
C'est c'est sûr qu'il n il y a jamais eu
de petite furine sur un virus de type
ça. Merde !
Revenons à nos moutons. Le micro, ça va
? C'est bien, ça se passe bien.
L'ingénieur du son, il gueule pas. Donc
on est impeccable.
Revenons, revenons à notre virus.
Comment vous en tant que français, père
de famille ou travaillant journaliste,
vous vous anticipez l'avenir sur les
deux prochaines années ? Est-ce que
Est-ce que vous vous attendez à des des
variants bien énervés, multivariants,
polyvariant avec les les capacités
agressives de tous les variants qu'on a
pu rencontrer comme le sud-africain, le
brésilien, l'indien ? Est-ce que vous
attendez à ce que ça se dégonfle un
petit peu, qu'on puisse reprendre une
vie un peu plus cool ou est-ce que vous
vous attendez à ce que ça chauffe
genre comme dans les films catastrophe ?
Bah là, moi je suis je sais pas je peux
pas vous dire ça, j'ai pas de boule de
cristal, hein. Après, j'en ai parlé hier
avec Étienne de Croly du variant indien
qui est le premier qui l'inquiète en
fait parce qu'il il a une mutation
justement sur ce site Furine
dit polyasique aussi parce qu'il a
plusieurs acides aminés basiques et
[grognement] la mutation a rajouté un
donc donc
ça pourrait expliquer un effet de
contagion encore plus fort Et
donc voilà. Après, quels seront les
autres ? Normalement, on aurait pu
espérer que les les variant rendent le
virus moins moins virulent
comme ça arrive souvent au bout d'un
moment quoi. Mais là, pour l'instant,
c'est pas encore le cas. C'est
question internet. En quoi selon lui
collaborer avec une université chinoise
est-il un conflit d'intérêt ?
Ben, c'est un conflit d'intérêt. Si vous
ben si par exemple vous collaborez avec
un un laboratoire qui est suspecté enfin
qui qui serait le premier euh à
inspecter pour faire une fuite de en cas
de fuite de laboratoire, bah si c'est
vous qui travaillez avec eux qui les
financ, c'est vos amis, ben vous c'est
pas c'est pas un mal. Vous il y a pas de
mal à travailler avec eux mais vous êtes
un peu mal placé pour être un arbitre
objectif. Je vais dire
question internet de Micron 2022.
[rires]
Pouvez-vous prouver votre indépendance ?
Non.
Je sais pas. Comment prouver mon
indépendance ? Indépendance par rapport
à qui ?
Mais j'ai pas de patron en tout cas.
Donc
vous êtes votre [rires] propre patron.
Voilà,
je suis en train de lire les les les
questions d'internet là. Impeccable.
Vous avez un avis sur les vaccins ?
sur les vaccins mais là c'est pas non
plus encore vraiment mon domaine.
Vous allez vous faire vacciner vous
quand on vous le proposera ?
Je sais pas [grognement] ça me regarde
pas.
Ça me regarde pas mais a priori pourquoi
Alors question internet. Le porte-avion
Charles de Gaulle est justement en plein
exercice militaire avec l'armée
indienne. Lorsque ces exercices y a-t-il
pas de rencontre physique de des escales
? La grande muette pourrait-elle être le
prochain cluster ? Arrêtez de me faire
sauter les lignes, merci.
Du nouveau variant indien. Le
coronavirus est-il un virus de type 3
sur 4 dans le classement des dangers
biologiques et qui peut être manipulé
dans les laxos P3 très nombreux partout
dans le monde ? Pourquoi cette
focalisation sur One et le laboratoire
P4 en particulier alors que ce virus
n'est pas de type 4 ? Bah, ça c'est tout
à fait juste. D'ailleurs euh la fois
qu'elle descende sur le laboratoire P4,
elle est pas bonne parce que
euh les coronavirus sont pas travaillés
dans les laboratoires P4 et on s'est
beaucoup euh enfin, on a beaucoup parlé
du laboratoire P4 parce qu'il avait été
construit avec la France et que c'était
le premier laboratoire P4 en Chine. Mais
en fait s'il y a eu un accident avec le
coronavirus, c'est probablement pas dans
le laboratoire P4 mais le va desp3 desp
donc et est en fait une ville où il y a
beaucoup de laboratoires P3 et il y a
pas que le WIV, c'est il y a il y a au
moins trois laboratoires institut et
laboratoires qui travaillent sur les
coronavirus à Onean avec des
laboratoires P3 voire des laboratoires
P2 et qui sont encore moins ben avec des
mesures de sécurité qui sont moindres.
Donc oui, le P4 c'est c'est c'est ça, je
sais pas, ça a fait beaucoup parler le
P4 mais c'est sans doute pas là que ça
s'est passé s'il s'est passé quelque
chose.
Est-ce que vous avez euh discuté avec
vos collègues journalistes de tout ça ?
Est-ce qu'ils vous ont mis, ils vous ont
dit calme-toi un petit peu, tu sais,
c'est pas un sujet très à la mode en ce
moment ou ils t'ont dit non, ils ont ils
ont rien dit ou vous vous avez peut-être
pas parlé avec eux.
Ben non, on m'a pas vraiment dit ça. Là,
je me souviens plus pour ce bouquin.
Bon, j'ai vu des copains mais mais je me
suis quand même pas mal mis autoconfiné
parce que c'est un livre qui s'est fait
ouais pendant 3 4 mois. J'ai été
beaucoup travaillé quoi et de chez moi
quoi sans sans aller voir grand monde.
Le Belling 4 des virus.
Le quoi ?
Le Belling 4.
C'est qui Belling 4 ?
Un mec qui fait du bon boulot pour pour
choper des tout un tas de choses sur
internet.
Ah ouais,
un bon data journaliste.
D'accord.
Alors, question internet. Pourquoi tirer
sur les Chinois alors que tout cela
pouvait venir des animaux et donc hors
de la Chine étant donné que le virus
s'est très vite répandu ?
Euh pourquoi tirer sur les Chinois ?
J'essagis pas de tirer sur les Chinois
et des animaux qui ça c'est un peu le
discours chinois d'ailleurs la question
mais qui peuvent venir d'animaux hors de
Chine. Ah mais tout à fait c'est
possible.
Après c'est comment ça arrive quoi ? Et
c'est vrai que
tout le discours chinois et et de Peter
d'Azac et de c'est d'aller chercher
ailleurs quoi, d'aller chercher alors
enie Sudest, en Thaïlande, en Cambodge
ou alors en Italie ou en France ou aux
États-Unis voir dans des laboratoires
parce que c'est ça qui est si étonnant
un peu avec les autorités chinoises,
c'est qu' ils reprennent l'hypothèse du
land 7 que c'est parler d'un
laboratoire, c'est une fuite accident
enfin un
un truc un virus pas naturel, c'est de
la théorie de la conspiration. Par
contre, eux ont dès le mois de janvier
diffusé l'idée que en fait ça venait
d'un laboratoire américain
et ça ça a été eu
bah vous avez des journaux chinois après
vous avez carrément eu au printemps
c'était des des portees-paroles du
ministère des affaires étrangères
chinois et encore au mois de janvier
cette année
et encore le jour même de la de la
conférence de presse de la mission de de
l'eman qui qui voulait carter
l'hypothèse du laboratoire, il y avait
une autorité chinoise qui encore mettait
de doigt sur un laboratoire américain
qui s'appelle Fortric et aussi sur le
fait que les Américains construit 200
laboratoires à travers le monde.
Donc c'était c'est assez cocass en fait
de voir que c'est une théorie du complot
quand c'est un laboratoire chinois mais
pas si c'est un laboratoire américain.
En fait, il faudra aller voir tous les
laboratoires si on voulait être fixé sur
cette histoire. sont bien encadrés
d'ailleurs ces est-ce qu'il y a il y a
un organisme supranational qui est censé
regarder ce qui se passe
B pas trop non c'est la différence par
exemple avec il y a pas une l'équivalent
de l'agence internationale pour le
nucléaire
et ça c'est ce qu'on ce que soulève un
type d'ailleurs de drastique que on n
pas encore pris la mesure en fait du
risque des laboratoires de haute
sécurité et que il y a pas les mêmes
précautions que pour des centrales
nucléaires alors qu'en fait le risque Et
dans le passé, il y a dans le passé, il
y a déjà eu des cartons, par exemple des
virologues qui qui se baladaient avec
des souches virales pour donner à des
copains et qui laissaient la souche
virale pendant 3 jours sur leur étagère
ou des virus qui se sont qui se sont
déjà échappés de de laboratoire. Ça
c'est déjà vu ou
ça ? Ça c'est déjà arrivé. Des virus qui
s'échappent de laboratoire avec le SARS.
Avec le SARS, c'est arrivé au moins
quatre trois fois.
Euh
bah des accidents, des gens qui peuvent
se piquer, qui peuvent peuvent se Ouais,
c'est un truc qui déborde, une morsure
d'animal. Ça peut être il y a il y a il
y a plusieurs façons d'avoir des des des
accidents, des fuites. Ça peut être par
les déchets, ça peut être par
Et c'est vrai que le SARS, on a deux
fois en Chine, deux fois à Pékin, il y
avait une fois un mort mais on avait pu
stopper le ça avait été repéré assez
vite et on avait pu stopper la chaîne de
contamination avec un virus qui était
moins qui était moins moins contagieux.
Est-ce que vous êtes intéressé sur les
protocoles de sécurité sur les
laboratoires P1, P2, P3, P4 et que vous
êtes intéressé plus particulièrement sur
le criblage des employés quand ils vont
bosser là-bas ? Est-ce qu'il y a une
enquête de proximité suffisamment
profonde pour savoir si c'est pas des
cinglés, si c'est pas des terroristes,
si c'est pas des militants politiques ou
des choses comme ça ?
Je crois pas qu'il est et et notamment,
ils sont très nombreux.
Euh un expert m'a dit "Ce qui est
étonnant euh un habitué de la Chine,
c'est que là-bas euh en gros en France,
vous avez un un chef de projet, un poste
doc avec lui et puis il y a un assistant
là-bas vous multipliez tout par 10 donc
vous avez beaucoup de monde et je pense
pas qu'on fasse des enquêtes non sur les
les gens qui travaillent dans un
laboratoire
en France.
En France non plus, personne m'a dit
qu'il y avait des enquêtes sur les
Après, en France, on fait des travaux
moins dangereux. On fait pas la France
n'est pas à la pointe des gains de
fonction sur les virus
et le laboratoire sur les coronavirus,
le meilleur c'est celui de Marseille.
Ils ne font pas ça. Mais c'est aussi par
éthique ou par qui trouve c'est risqué.
Et il y a des il y a aussi des manières
de faire autrement. Plutôt que de
rajouter une fonction, on peut l'enlever
pour voir à quoi sert la fonction. Ou
alors on peut avoir des pseud des
pseudotypes, des virus qui sont pas
vraiment des virus donc qui sont
mais il y a une incitation en fait de la
communauté internationale et des des
revues à travailler sur des à faire des
vrais virus dangereux parce que c'est
comme si c'était un peu spectaculaire.
Qu'est-ce qu'est-ce que vous vous gardez
de ce livre ? Vous gardez certes une
grande connaissance, je suis sûr que
vous vous êtes formé
autour de ce sujet-là d'une façon
profonde. Qu'est-ce que vous en gardez ?
Vous en gardez quoi ? Le fait qu'on est
entre de bonnes mains, qu'on a une bonne
presse, qu'on a des des gens de notre
administration qui qui nous protègent.
Vous vous en gardez quoi ? fait des
choses positives.
Bah bien sûr tout ça.
[rires]
Non mais il y a de quoi, je suis désolé,
je vais parler un peu d'une façon plus
familière mais il y a de quoi se taper
des bonnes barres de rire et de peur
dans ce bouquin là. C'est flippant quand
même.
Bah c'est flippant de quoi la compétence
ou des choses comme ça ?
[rires]
Je sais pas moi, j'ai pas de jugement
généraux comme ça, mais c'est sûr qu' il
y a des préjugés dans la il y a trop de
préjugés, je trouve, aussi bien dans la
presse que dans les chez chez les
dirigeants et on part dans un sens
en ce moment, il y a ce cette chappe un
peu de complotiste aussi qui est assez
assez forte, qui permet de de
discréditer un truc de façon assez
là là pour ce ce cet exemple. C'est
vraiment exemple un peu parastque de de
voir un accident de laboratoire. C'est
un complot. C'est c'est c'est juste
ridicule en fait.
On sait pas si c'est un accident de la
Non mais l'hypothèse d'un accident de
laboratoire que ce soit un complot,
c'est juste ridicule. C'est juste une
hypothèse. Il y a il y a pas de dessin
derrière de un complot. Je sais pas
c'est des gens qui complotent pour faire
quelque chose. Là si vous avez quelqu'un
qui s'est fait mordre par une souris
pour rien. Personne n c'est un accident
quoi en fait. Donc envisager un
accident, ça a été catalogué comme un
complot, ce qui est ridicule en fait.
Question internet qui est revenu
d'ailleurs plus souvent souvent dans
dans le chat. Que pens que pensent-il de
Didi Raou ?
Mais pourquoi ces questions d'internet ?
C'est pas mon sujet. Adid Raou
moi Adid Raou je je l' interviewé et
après je suis pas j'ai pas jugé la
chloroquine l'effet de la chloroine.
Une question qui revient Avez-vous subi
des pressions des tentatives de
manipulation ?
Non.
Ça vous fait quoi de voir Agnès Busin à
l'OMS ?
Ah ben je sais pas [rires]
était récompensée euh [soupir]
bah elle elle aurait dû s'occuper par
exemple elle elle aurait dû être au
courant du sud de Furine c'était et au
lieu d'aller prendre la mairie de Paris
peut-être elle était au courant du s de
Furine elle serait dit que c'était
important de rester là je sais pas mais
à l'OMS ben bah là l'OMS c'est quand
même distingué on peut espérer que ça
change parce que vous avez quand même le
patron de l'OMS qui le jour même
[grognement] de la de la sortie du
rapport
l'a quasiment désavoué en fait parce que
le rapport
dit que l'hypothèse du labo est
extrêmement improbable. Il l' il l'a
balayé en fait très rapidement et le
jour même il dit qu'il faut pousser plus
loin cette hypothèse et que il est prêt
à envoyer une équipe spécialement
là-dessus.
Donc on va voir ce que ce que va faire
le match. Je sais pas si Agè Busin
va avoir un rôle là-dedans.
Euh dernière question internet.
Alors
bah non, pas de dernière question
internet. Alors
alors lorsque l'on voit le désastre
indien et brésilien qui sont des pays
chauds, peut-on s'inquiéter que ces
variances ils arrivent sur le territoire
entre parenthèses sans doute déjà le cas
provoque des pics d'épidémie cet été. ce
qui terminerait sans doute ce qui reste
de l'économie réelle notamment
saisonnière éventuellement et
événementiel. Vous êtes pas médecin,
vous êtes pas virologue, vous êtes
journaliste, vous pouvez pas nous faire
des prévisions sur
Je pas je veux bien me garder de faire
des prévisions, mais tout ce que je peux
vous dire, c'est que le Arian Indien
vous en tant que genou
il inquiète Étienne de Croly pour une
raison une bonne raison parce que vous
avez un acide aminé basique de plus dans
le site et donc déjà que ce site il
était pas bon. Vous vous en tant que que
journaliste, quand vous voyez tous ces
experts de plateau télé défiler à dire
tout et son contraire selon les mois
ségréant, ça vous fait quoi qu'on les
réinvite toujours sur les plateaux télé
?
Bah, il faut bien inviter des gens sans
doute hein. Faut faire du remplissage
après.
C'est du remplissage.
Bah, il faut remplir les plateaux.
Après, je je sais pas les les quelle est
leur compéten ?
Moi je veux pas trop juger des gens.
Gentil. [grognement]
Ouais.
Question internet. Avez-vous étudié le
lien entre l'humidité et coronavirus ?
L'Inde n'a connu qu'une seule vague qui
correspond à la saison des pluies. Le
Brésil a un climat tropical. L'humidité
serait-elle un propagateur important du
virus ?
Ça, je là encore je dis moi, j'ai fait
une enquête sur l'origine du virus. Donc
je suis pas un virologue mais je crois
que ce virus bah il y a quand même
apparemment nous on a eu
un impact un peu de la météo quand même.
Ça ça ça a joué mais moins qu'avec
d'autres virus respiratoires. Donc
c'est c'est vrai qu'il est il est il est
étonnant. Il est
on arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Ça fait combien de temps ? Ça va faire 1
heure et demi qu'on ensemble. Euh est-ce
que vous avez trois livres à conseiller
à notre communauté ?
Euh ouais. Et ben [grognement] j' avais
pensé
je pensais qu'on parlerait d'autres
choses mais j'avais un livrez attendez
attendez. Vous voulez parler de quoi ?
Je sais pas. Non
des préjugés. Moi je trouvais que
c'était
Allez allez, on a le temps.
Pour quoi les préjugés ?
Des préjugés dans la presse, moi je
pensais qu'on allait un peu parler qui
qui des des des sujets voilà qui sont
qu'on qu'on a tendance à pas traiter.
Mais c'est des préjugés par rapport à
quoi ? Quel type de sujet ? C'est des
préjugés pourquoi ? Parce que nos
journalistes à 80 % sont des militants
politiques drapés dans l'étendard de la
vertu journalistique et qui parta
comment redire ren
ou Ouais. Non mais on on la passe en
replay.
euh parce que c'est des militants
politiques, ils ont leur préjugés de
militants politique ou parce que ils
sont ils ont leur leur historique. C'est
c'est quoi ? Des préjugés dans la presse
ou des préjugés dans les capacités qu'on
a de développer notre esprit critique ?
Est-ce que on se met des barrières dans
notre esprit critique ?
Moi, je pense qu'il y a des choses qu'on
regarde pas. Bah là, ça a été le cas
pendant longtemps. Celui-ci aujourd'hui
ça ça tourne mais [grognement]
moi j'ai démarré il y a longtemps
maintenant mais j'avais fait un j'ai
commencé avec des films sur la Savoie
enfin j'avais fait un film sur les
indépendantistes dans Savoie et et
j'avais été étonné au début c'était un
producteur qui m'avait demandé chercher
un sujet tout ça. Je connaissais pas
plus que ça. J'étais pas du tout
partisan de cette cause. Mais mais du
coup, je m'étais penché là-dessus parce
qu'on était parti pour faire ce film et
j'avais vu comment un
bah un mouvement comme ça un parti et
peut être traité tout de suite de
populiste, de discrédité en fait
d'extrême droite ou des choses comme ça
alors que c'était absolument pas le cas
quoi.
Après, j'ai enchaîné, j'ai fait
je voulais faire un film sur un
biologiste qui s'appelait Mirko
Belganski qui avait été aussi
ben catalogué comme c'était devenu même
un gourou et et j'avais vu des choses
comme ça dès le début. J'ai vu un peu
des des sujets qui sont catalogués. Moi,
j'ai eu dans ma carrière, j'ai j'ai eu
l'occasion de voir ça. C'est ça qui m'a
amené à monter un journal en savoir
faire un petit peu les choses que je
voulais euh et aujourd'hui m'orienter
plus vers l'édition parce que je trouve
que l'édition permet plus de d'aborder
bah déjà des sujets plus en longueur
mais bon voilà, on va pas s'étendre non
plus là-dessus.
Sin vous allez revenir, [rires] pourquoi
pas ?
Pourquoi pas ? Et euh trois trois livres
pour notre communauté. Et ben il y
aurait j'avais pensé [rires]
que est-ce que vous connaissez la charte
de Munich ? La charte de
question d'internet ça que vous posez
tout le temps. La charte Dominique, je
la connais par cœur mais ça me paraît
qu' des questions de bon sens en fait
d'être honnête quoi. La charte de
ministre c'est de l'honnêteté et puis on
peut la résumer en un article quoi. Non
je sais pas
c'est quoi quel article ? Ben je vous
dis l'honnêteté intellectuelle et
l'honnêteté tout court quoi. De pas
avoir d'impartialité, être de pas c'est
ça je connais pas les articles de la
charque deunite, j'en connais aucun par
cœur mais je me doute que l'esprit c'est
ça quoi. Et qu'il y a pas besoin de
connaître la charte dominique pour
essayer de faire son boulot honnêtement.
Pour certains, il faut leur rappeler de
temps en temps.
Mais donc ouais un livre que j'avais
aimé c'était l'avenir est notre affaire
de Denis de Rougement. Attendez, je vous
coupe parce que là ils viennent tous de
me poser leurs questions.
Quels sont les sujets interdits ou
préjugés dans les médias ?
Je sais pas. Moi, j'ai j'ai dernièrement
j'ai fait des trucs aussi sur la Corse.
La Corse c'est un sujet qu'on a du mal à
traiter la l'action de l'État en Corse
par exemple.
Euh
même des même l'État n'en parle pas
beaucoup. D'ailleurs, j'ai fait des
papiers où j'ai c'était quasiment
impossible d'interroger les on se
faisait balader de
de la préfecture de Corse, des
ministères.
C'est quoi des pinsout qui vous bal qui
vous bal ?
Non, c'était des autorités. Vous voulez
interroger des gens sur des sujets
précis et personne vous parle. J'ai eu
une interview d'une ministre qui a été
refusée après après être faite quoi
parce qu'elle elle avait pas le droit de
parler en fait. Il fallait pas parler de
la Corse. Et je vois aussi que ce que la
l'État la gouvernement s'est pas très
bien comporté avec la Corse de manière
pas très honnête avec même en
instrumentisant la justice des choses
comme ça. Et vous voyez pas trop
d'articles là-dessus.
Après, je sais pas, on parlait des
vaccins tout à l'heure. Les vaccins,
c'est aussi un sujet qui est qui est
délicat à traiter parce que en ce moment
c'est voilà en ce moment mais déjà un
peu avant parce que c'est vous avez si
si vous émettez une remarque ou c'est
antivaccinologue, c'est c'est antivax.
Si euh et tout de suite il y a
l'éculation d'antiv, de l'autre côté,
vous avez des antivax qui disent les
vaccins c'est des poisons et tout ça.
Moi, je je connais bien euh un mec qui
s'appelle Romain Gérardi qui est
chercheur qui est professeur de médecine
et qui a travaillé sur l'aluminium. Par
exemple, le sujet de ce qu'il a trouvé
sur aluminium, il est très difficilement
traitable, il est complètement
obscur et il amène les gens à dire
n'importe quoi sur d'extrapoler ses
travaux parce qu'il a trouvé que
l'aluminium pouvait poser des problèmes
dans certains cas limités et des
problèmes bien caractérisés. Euh et ça
on l'écarte parce qu'il faut ne dire
qu'il y a aucun problème avec les
vaccins parce que sinon ça va être c'est
faut qu'il y a rien faut faut il y a
aucune critique et puis les gens qui
conna qui ont entendu vivement parler de
ça vaguement parler de ça ils vont vous
dire que les vaccins sont des poison que
il faut les donner il faut faut voilà
que c'est faut jamais en prendre qu'il
faut pas se vacciner ça c'est un sujet
typique qui est difficile à traiter avec
la nuance en fait c'est c'est souvent ça
qui est aujourd'hui c'est tout dans un
sens souvent
bah c'est ce qui fait vendre non les les
choses clivantes
peut-être
sa prendre le temps donner du temps aux
gens pour parler sans montage sans
coupure sans pub c'est c'est compliqué
hein au 21e siècle bienvenue chezw
ben merci [grognement]
nos trois bouquins. Ouais. Donc je vous
disais l'avenir est notre affaire de
Denis Rougemont qui est un un auteur que
que j'ai bien aimé qui est
un un peu un des premiers enfin pas les
premiers mais dans les années 70 qui
était qui avait parlé de la religion de
la croissance et qui ramenait un peu
à une autre Europe qui ramenait aussi au
niveau de la démocratie vers la commune
vers les régions
et donc c'est un livre qui m'a un peu
inspiré. J'ai par sympathie avec une
personne que j'ai rencontré pendant
cette enquête
exus d' excise d'un soir de Rodolph de
Mess qui est un membre de drastique et
qui fait un livre sur en lien avec son
aul qui est un illustre écrivain
savoyard qui s'appelle Joseph de Mestre
et qui parle de d'un retour un peu de
l'esprit dans la science quoi pour les
pour les années qui viennent comme
l'avait un peu prévu son ancêtre.
Et puis un troisième, bah ça serait
celui d'un très bon ami qui s'appelle
Vincent Cogt qui a écrit la civilisation
du cocon qui est sorti dernièrement et
qui incite un peu à sortir de sa bulle
parce qu'on a tendance c'est confortable
de se mettre dans une bulle dans un
cocon que ça soit dans son appartement
ou dans son cercle d'amis dans son dans
sa communauté c'est c'est j'ai rien
contre les communautés c'est je pense
que c'est pas mal d'avoir des
communautés mais c'est bien aussi d'en
sortir et de et donc la civilisation du
cocon amène à ça et C'est je pense que
c'est valable dans tous les milieux,
dans la presse ou pour tout le monde
quoi.
Est-ce que vous pouvez montrer ce livre
là à l'écran et me lire quelques lignes
qui a marqué derrière ?
Ah bah celui-ci c'est celui que je
recommande aussi, c'est sûr. C'est
c'est le tien
aux origines du mal. Et
faut montrer à la caméra. Faut le
montrer à la caméra. On a un caméraman
qui est payé que pour ça. Attention, on
lui montre
l'autre côté. L'autre côté, c'est mieux.
Et je lis. Vous voulez que je lise quoi
? La 4è de coup.
Ouais, ouais, ouais.
Et ben ce livre révèle pourquoi et
comment la fausse piste du pangolin a
permis d'écarter ou de négliger d'autres
scénarios plus dérangeants, les enjeux
géopolitiques, le rôle clé de certains
scientifiques, parties prenantes ou
sous-influence, les médias manipulés. Il
exume les histoires oubliées, questionne
aussi les manipulations menées dans les
laboratoires de virologie sur les virus
les plus dangereux de la planète.
Voilà. Après le 4 mars, je vous dis
toute la 4e de cour mars dernier après
l'échec de la mission de l'Organisation
mondiale de la santé, une trentaine de
scientifiques du monde entier ont
réclamé de façon solennelle une enquête
approfondie et crédible qui ne devrait
exclure aucune piste qui devrait exclure
aucune piste. le vent a commencé à
tourner et c'est vrai que dans ce livre,
je j'ai écrit un peu en même temps que
je continuais à enquêter,
on sent un vent qui tourne avec avec
cette histoire dès le dès le début et la
fin cette bah cette lettre qu'on fait
les la trentaine de scientifiques dont
Étienne de Croly, on parle beaucoup du
groupe de Paris qui serait derrière
cette lettre mais en fait c'est plutôt
un groupe qui part de Marseille en fait
et c'est mais qui a eu qui a une
audience internationale énorme
aujourd'hui et qui a qui a changé la
donne et c'est un sujet justement qui
devrait sortir des préjugés.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ?
Et ben ne pas en avoir des préjugés si
je vais un conseil à faire parce que
garder l'esprit ouvert, profiter de
leurs proches et aller voir ailleurs
aussi quoi.
Comment on fait pour pas avoir de
préjugés ? Ah, c'est dur parce que la
vie nous conditionne, hein. On est
conditionné un peu de tous les côtés
mais
l'ouverture d'esprit, je sais pas, la
curiosité euh
et se remettre un peu en question, euh
mais c'est ça l'ouvert essayer de pas
être conditionné quoi. C'est ce qui est
difficile parce que le conditionnement
c'est ce qui marche le mieux sans doute
au monde.
Brisperrier, merci.
Merci à vous.
[musique]